hello everyone and welcome to the August
2023 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll this is the week after I
released my solo episode on the crisis
in physics I just wanted to say that I'm
quite gratified at the reception that it
has gotten uh there are if you ask what
I mean by the reception there are
various places where people can talk
about uh the podcast episodes of course
patreon supporters who are the one
asking the questions for these ask me
anything episodes can do so on patreon
we have a somewhat active group there
there is a Sean Carroll subreddit
s-e-a-n-c-a-r-r-o-l-l where people could
talk about podcast episodes but also
other things that I do and so forth
there's also comments that come up on
Twitter and YouTube and and what have
you and people seem to like the solo
episode and they took it in the spirit I
think that it is offered which is it's
not primarily polemical right it's not
primarily there it wasn't primarily
there to persuade you to have a certain
point of view I have a point of view and
I'm trying to explain to you what my
point of view is but also it's mostly to
help you understand why physicists do
the things they do you're allowed to
disagree with how physicists go about
their business and what problems they
choose to tackle and how they choose to
do so but you should do so everyone
should do so from a situation from a
standpoint of understanding why they're
doing the things they do and that was
really the primary point of the episode
and why it was so long because I got to
sort of expound on the whole history of
20th century and now 21st century
physics there are a couple of people of
course who just snarked about it but if
you look carefully at their snark it was
also completely clear that they didn't
listen to the episode so the lesson I'm
taking from this is that all of my
episodes should be four hours long and
then the people who want to snark about
them will clearly be not very relevant
to the actual discussion probably not
going to happen four hours a lot of time
I don't know if it's clear you know that
I it was not a single sitting that I did
that episode in but sometimes you have a
lot to say and you got to keep talking
about it I also wanted to express
appreciation because the recent episode
with Katie Elliott was also very well
received and you never know you know
it's a many episodes are slightly
different from each other Katie was uh
kind enough to come on and rather than
just talk about her specific work help
us give a general chat about metaphysics
and what it is and what it's for and
people really liked it which I thought
was great and so kudos to Katie for that
and also she it was very good at asking
me questions and having it really be a
conversation that's hard to do for many
uh guests you know depending on what
their thing is they're doing for a
living why would they have any questions
for me but hopefully it came through why
I think that the physics science I
should say slash philosophy boundary is
such an incredibly fertile area to think
about things philosophy does have
something to offer and physics
absolutely has some questions that uh
they have some answers to that will help
the philosophers but they have some
questions that they can use
philosophical help with
I should also say that I've been on a
couple of other podcasts lately most uh
notably a couple of episodes of
Robinson's podcast Robinson Earhart does
a very nice podcast where he gets a lot
of philosophers and other thinkers on so
recently I was on with David Albert
talking about quantum mechanics and
boltzmann brains and things like that I
was also on a episode of his podcast
with slavoy zizak the famous in certain
circles extremely well-known
psychoanalytic philosopher Slovenian and
quite a character also and and slavoy
apparently is thinking very hard about
quantum mechanics these days so uh poor
Robinson got to say very little in the
podcast because it was basically slavoy
was the host and he was giving his
opinion and then asking me questions so
you can you can look that one up on the
Internet sits on YouTube and elsewhere
otherwise remember these ask me anything
episodes are sponsored by patreon
supporters of the mindscape podcast and
YouTube
could be a patreon supporter go to
patreon.com Sean M Carroll and Pledge
Your one dollar per episode or whatever
you want per episode no one has yet
pledged a thousand dollars per episode
but I don't discourage it you're allowed
to I hope that there's no one out there
who's really been wanting to pledge a
thousand dollars per episode and thought
that I would be insulted I would not be
pledge whatever you want or pledge
nothing at all we love all mindscape
listeners equally but we appreciate the
support from patreons so with that let's
go
foreign
[Music]
as I'm doing this recording there's a
few hot topics out there in the sciency
physicsy discourse going on so naturally
I get some questions about them and so
I'm going to start by grouping together
uh some questions on these various
topics and sort of giving you a
collective answer I don't have anything
very deep to say about any of them but
I'll explain why I don't have deep
things to say about them so the first
one is two questions I'm going to group
together one is from Anonymous who says
can you weigh in on the plausibility of
the room temperature atmospheric
pressure superconductor papers released
archive last week I realize it's paper
reading but I would be surprised if you
haven't brought it up before if you if
you just have judgment without reading
it'd be interesting as well and supendu
harsh says are you satisfied with the
evidence for room temperature
superconductor LK 99 or do you think
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof so for those those
of you who have a very different social
media feed than I do there have been a
couple papers there were a couple papers
I don't know a couple weeks ago now
maybe uh from a group in Korea it's a
little South Korea there's a little bit
of um
confusion about why there are two papers
and they don't have exactly the same
author lists and there's one person
who's on one paper but not the other and
one of the papers has six authors and
one of the papers has three authors and
some people are saying well the three
author paper was trying to get their
names out there so that they could be
the three Nobel Prize winners if this is
true I have no idea so I've not actually
read the papers no I've I've glanced at
the papers but there's another level of
reading if you want to really understand
things at a physics level and I have not
done that but the claim is that they
have a room temperature atmospheric
pressure superconductor for those of you
who are not super familiar here
superconductors are just materials that
have no electrical resistance you can
send a curry current down them without
losing any of that current or without
even really putting any effort into it
at all it would be a very big deal
technologically if you had easily
makeable room temperature atmospheric
pressure superconductors you have to say
atmosphere pressure there because you
can create higher temperature
superconductors by putting an almost
amount of pressure on them but that kind
of removes the whole benefit of just
having something that you can put in
your computer no problem right we have
high temperature superconductors which
are very very big deal in physics but
high temperature just means High
compared to absolute zero Kelvin these
are still quite low temperature compared
to room temperature and the the more
this new claim is that you actually have
room temperature superconductors which
are things that people have hoped for
and looked for for quite a while
so I will say that I'm a little
skeptical I am not on the bandwagging
bandwagon saying that this is probably
going to be right if I had to bet at
even money I would say it's going to go
away uh there's various pieces of
evidence that are given here one of them
is that you can sort of float a little
piece of material above the
superconductor and that is evidence that
the purported superconductor is
expelling magnetic field lines the
meissner effect and this is evidence for
superconductivity but there's also as it
turns out other ways to get that kind of
behavior that don't necessarily rely on
ordinary superconductivity and the other
thing about these papers and all I know
is from you know reading people who are
actually experts I'm a physicist but I'm
not a condensed matter physicist not a
superconducting expert as I've said
before though I am an expert on sort of
knowing how reasonable physics claims
sound uh AB initio or abriari or
whatever you want to call it so it's
just a little little shaky you know
um they the plot in the paper as I
understand it that purports to establish
superconductivity number one doesn't
look like superconductivity in the sense
that when you have a superconducting
transition it's a phase transition and
you plot the electrical resistance as a
function of temperature and it tends to
have a discontinuity near the
superconducting phase transition and in
these papers it doesn't it sort of
gradually goes down to the lower level
and of course you can't measure a number
that is exactly zero so you have some
measurement uncertainty when you're
measuring the superconductivity or the
conductivity or resistivity which is one
over the conductivity and in as I
understand it again from what other
people are saying and you know
reproducing plots and things like that
there's basically two different samples
that the original papers looked at one
is a relatively thick slab of the stuff
and it doesn't even conduct as well as
copper does it doesn't it's definitely
no evidence for superconducting in this
thing the other sample is a thinner film
and it conducts better because maybe
because it's thinner right uh so I it
doesn't smell like real to me uh I am
not
um averse to there being room
temperature superconductors uh there's
no law of physics it says that can't be
true there's nothing special about room
temperature right it's just what how
where we happen to live so I'm very
open-minded about the possibility of
room temperature superconductors being
discovered and maybe there's something
interesting going on with this
particular
object LK 99 this particular substance
but it is hard you know
doing physics at a very precise high
level is just hard so it's very very
easy to trick yourself if all all the
bases are not covered Etc and the people
who are experts who have looked at this
are like well you know maybe it's true
but it doesn't you know kind of fit
together it doesn't kind of seem like
what you would expect so I would say
that it's absolutely possible I
certainly let me put it this way hope
that it is it would be awesome if it is
so I'm kind of rooting for it
but there's a whole other aspect to talk
about which is the fact that it's
actually not that hard to synthesize
this material LK 99 following the
instructions in the papers so this is
not like searching for supersymmetry at
the Large Hadron glider where you need a
10 billion dollar particle accelerator
if you have various lab equipment pieces
already in place you can just do it
yourself and what this has led to is a
whole bunch of people some of them are
at established Labs others are it's a
little unclear where they are trying in
real time to reproduce these results and
see whether or not they can check it out
I have strongly mixed feelings about
this whole thing on the one hand I feel
very positively about the fact that if
you can do it if you have the technology
to participate in the science uh search
then great you know the more people the
better that is wonderful on the other
hand it does the the fact that so much
of it is being done in real time in
public thick might be fun for the
spectators but it does not lead to the
best science you know science has as its
product something that should be widely
shared and understood by everybody but
there is a moment in the doing of
science when you need to be careful and
quiet and by yourself you know and
really concentrate on getting it right
and having people like following your
every move and cheering you on while
you're doing it that is not conducive to
the most careful scientific practice
I think that in the modern world it's so
easy to put things out there in public
right
to put various work that you're doing or
ideas that you have and overall that is
a good thing I think but I do notice
that you know when I talk about a
workshop I was at or a talk I went to or
am planning for the future uh people
will always ask you know is it online is
it is it being streamed so we can see it
and sometimes the answer is yes and
sometimes the answer is no it's
perfectly legitimate question is it is
it going to be online but then sometimes
when the answer is no uh I will get
responses like well that's not how
science should be done you should put
everything online and I just don't think
that's true I don't think you should put
everything online there has to be a
place for people just to talk without
the whole world looking over their
shoulder and that's just for theorists
who are relatively low stakes in this
game right for experimentalists who are
trying to do very very careful testing
and measuring of quantities and there's
expectations and it would be World
shattering If This Were true well not
shattering but changing it would have an
effect on the world if you had a room
temperature superconductor that was
easily synthesized so the pressure is on
and that's not the kind of situation
that under which we do our best science
let's put it that way so I have very
mixed feelings about the public nature
of people trying to reproduce this and
also just the impatience like you know
the day-to-day oh this person did this
this person did that that's also not
really conducive to good scientific
practice it's you know it's kind of like
if you are very good at playing the
piano you can have a concert and people
can come and listen to your concert and
that's great but you have to practice
there's some parts of your Mastery of
playing a musical instrument that are
private by construction and likewise for
science there should be a public aspect
and a private aspect and I worry that
this kind of thing is a a little bit too
messy and out there and it's getting
people too excited too quickly like
sometimes science has to be careful and
slow and I'm not sure whether this is
going to uh be the best example of that
okay the next set of questions is about
Oppenheimer uh so what did you think of
AJ says so what did you think of
Oppenheimer the movie uh Carlos Nunes
says what is your opinion of the new
movie about a Robert Oppenheimer by
Christopher Nolan do you think the
physics is represented accurately and if
not what would you have done differently
I did see Oppenheimer also saw barbie
which is the other part of the pair of
movies people are very excited about
these days I thought Oppenheimer was
brilliant honestly I am I was pleasantly
surprised at how much I liked it uh I am
generally a fan of Christopher Nolan but
I think that he's uneven I thought that
Memento his very first movie was genius
one of my favorite movies of all time uh
his subsequent movies I've seen good
bits in but you know every one of them
kind of uh had its ups and downs I think
Inception was really really good some
other movies were not as good uh so
Oppenheimer just blew me away it was a
three hour long bio pack of J Robert
Oppenheimer and I think that biopics are
just intrinsically very difficult to
pull off because human beings life
stories are not structured like a
three-act Hollywood movie right or not
structured dramatically more uh
generally there are ups and downs and
there's no you know culmination Etc and
so Nolan who wrote the script you know
based on a book called American American
Prometheus which was a biography of
Oppenheimer but he
pulled out all the stops in terms of
Storytelling he had two parallel tracks
going one of which was sort of up to
um you know from oppenheimer's Young
days as a physics graduate student up to
through through the Los Alamos Manhattan
Project and then up to his uh trial not
really trial I should say but if you
know oppenheimer's story he was at one
point the head of the Manhattan Project
and then not long after his security
clearance was taken away
it's a very controversial moment in the
history of American politics and its
relationship to science because you know
Oppenheimer would hang out with known
Communists uh his brother and I think
his wife also were were pretty much
admitted Communists and Oppenheimer was
a complicated guy who on the one hand he
built the atomic bomb you know he was in
charge of that project and he was very
proud of that project and he was very
much in favor of it he wasn't ambiguous
about that but then he also kind of felt
bad about the fact that oh it killed
hundreds of thousands of people and he
was partly responsible for that and you
can argue back and forth whether or not
well he shouldn't have felt bad because
he helped end World War II or he should
have felt way more than bad because he
killed a lot of people right and other
people say well he didn't kill a lot of
people the government you know so
there's a lot to be said about that it's
a complicated thing so that's one story
and then Nolan inserts another story
which he sort of tells in parallel it's
a it's a more more minor story but it's
about Lewis Strauss who was a trustee of
the institute for advanced studies who
helped hire Oppenheimer as the head of
the IIs but then also had his own
political issues he was nominated
ultimately for Secretary of Commerce I
think and
Congress refused to approve him for that
in part because of his uh betrayal of
Oppenheimer in a very real sense and so
um the I about the physics in the movie
you know it was fine I don't look at
movies like this as physics lectures
myself I'm not looking for the physics
to be 100 accurate I'm not even looking
for the history to be 100 accurate in
the following sense I don't want them to
dramatically misrepresent history I
don't want them to show things in a
movie based on historical events that
are really just completely opposite to
the sense of what actually happened but
people complaining that this or that
figure who was really playing a role at
Los Alamos but didn't appear in the
movie and whatever or Oppenheimer was
shown talking to Einstein when he's
really talking to somebody else I don't
care about that you know make a good
movie and I thought that uh Oppenheimer
was a good movie and it was very much as
far as I could tell
honest and
um careful about the spirit of what was
happening it was not really dramatically
misrepresenting people or events it
streams lines streamlines things to tell
a story and I think that's great so I
encourage people to see it as a long
movie I'm getting you know as I get
older it's harder for me to watch three
hour movies and and keep riveted the
whole time but this did a pretty darn
good job uh I was very impressed and I I
didn't think that it would be that
cinematic honestly so I was very happy
to see it come out that well
um there's also Barbie and I love Barbie
too you know Barbie is a whole other
movie it was very hilarious that it came
out at the same time and people got
excited about it like a couple months
ago someone on Twitter said you know
yeah these movies are coming out the
same day and I can't imagine there's a
very big group that's going to want to
see them both and I instantly replied
like okay I guess I'm in a very unusual
group because I definitely want to see
them both as it turns out lots of people
wanted to see them both and I love
barbecue it was it was a great movie I
think Oppenheimer was was better was you
know a higher level
um achievement it's really just a a
memorable movie for you know in in terms
of my whole history of watching movies
as far as this year is concerned I think
it's Barbie Oppenheimer and into the
spider-verse which were my favorite
movies this year
um and Barbie was just unapologetically
feminist and you know talks about the
patriarchy and everything but it does so
in such a light-hearted loving way
um and the you know there's no easy
resolution to the problem that Barbie is
a toy and you know it starts in Barbie
land and the toys don't really have the
kind of agency that you would want uh to
have if you were a functioning human
being and that's a structural problem
when you want to make movies about toys
right I think it Toy Story has some
philosophical issues with it for example
um but yeah it was just fun and super
well acted and again you know a little
bit long Barbie but uh it was it was
threading a needle of you know okay you
want to get you want to support Barbie
in her desire to have a more fulfilling
life but you don't want to do that at
the expense of anyone else and you know
Ryan Gosling who's playing Ken does an
amazing job as he starts the movie as
basically the only character in Barbie
land who is not satisfied right who's
not happy living in Barbie land and
that's telling because Barbie land is a
matriarchy and matriarchies aren't any
better than patriarchies right uh he is
just a secondary character and that's a
it's completely fair for him to be a
little bit dissatisfied and how do you
resolve that it's all very tricky I
encourage you to go see the movie it was
it was pretty awesome
okay final big topic of the last couple
weeks I'm going to group together
several questions on it Robert
ruxandrescue says what do you make of
the recent meeting in Congress on the
topic of uap's Slash UFOs for those of
you who don't know UFOs of course
unidentified flying objects but uaps are
the rebranding effort to try to make
them seem more respectable unidentified
aerial phenomena okay
Stevie CPW says in a cocktail-infused
debate with friends over the recent
Congressional inquiries about UFOs I
Proclaim that the more reports of
extraterrestrial events there are the
less likely they they were to be true my
argument argument sorry my argument was
based on the incredible odds in space
and time against even one visit from an
extraterrestrial let alone hundreds is
my logic flawed also what is your
opinion on this topic and do you think
that it could be a subject of a
congressional hearing should be subject
to Congressional hearing and then Ali
Wright says I am a natural skeptic but
the recent Congressional hearing on uaps
and in particular the UAP Amendment to
the National Defense authorization Act
contained stunning claims my question is
how would you suggest approaching this
situation what is a rational path that
avoids both conspiracy theory Wu but
also remaining open-minded in the
scientific sense The Great Deceiver
finally says first off did you watch any
of the hearings into UFOs even for fun
and if yes what are your thoughts so
I'll give you my general thoughts and I
I feel bad about giving you my general
thoughts because they do not line up
with some of the people asking the
questions sorry about that but I think
it's all complete nonsense
those are my general thoughts I do not
think that there's any evidence to be
taken seriously presented in those
hearings that should lead you to believe
that aliens are visiting the Earth in
their little spaceships and crashing and
being captured by the government and
kept from us in secret okay again it's
possible and again I kind of hope that
I'm wrong like that would be intriguing
but weird but but kind of awesome but I
would put that as way lower probability
than the superconducting stuff I suppose
I in the super conducting question I
should have been more clear in the
answer to
question do you think extraordinary
claims require extraordinary proof yeah
exactly absolutely I think that or but
the it's not that extraordinary claims
in the sense of it would be really
important if this is true require
extraordinary proof extraordinary in the
sense that your prior is really low
right as a good Bayesian you start with
priors and all these propositions and in
order to be persuaded that there is
substantial Credence in them you need
the data to come in more information to
come in that you judge the likelihood of
that data to be really really big if
this extraordinary claim is true and
really really small if it's not true
okay that's the kind of extraordinary
proof that you need and for the
superconducting stuff the proof is not
really that extraordinary right now but
you know who knows maybe it will firm up
for the UFO stuff the proof the evidence
is just laughable it is true that this
dude I forget what his name is went and
made claims to a congressional committee
that were quite astonishing claims let's
put it that way it's also true that he
has all of the Vibes of a complete
crackpot I mean at one point he was
talking about the holographic principle
and extra dimensions and stuff like that
if that didn't set up all of your alarm
Bells uh I'm not sure what would so the
two things to say are that first my
prior
on the idea that there are aliens
buzzing Us in UFOs and crashing and
being captured by the government is
extremely extremely low that whole
scenario makes no sense for many reasons
I've talked about it many times before
the whole idea that aliens are so
special sufficiently technologically
advanced that they can easily fly across
Interstellar distances uh and yet can't
and and try to avoid detection right
like they're not just landing on the
lawn of the White House and saying take
me to your leader right they're trying
to be cagey but they're not very good at
it so we get these fuzzy pictures of
them right
and then you know you you probably have
seen these maps of sightings of UFOs
worldwide and when you know they take a
map of the world and they put little
dots where there are sightings of UFOs
and they're basically all in the United
States
that would be weird right why would the
aliens so much care about the United
States that doesn't make a lot of sense
maybe there's something else going on
so I think it is it's just not the way
that it would happen if there were
really technologically advanced aliens
out there that they would Buzz us in
their spacecraft and then occasionally
crash and be captured by the government
that's just is very very low prior
probability on my chart and then you ask
okay well what is the evidence here well
what is the evidence it's a guy making
claims that's the evidence right it to
to change my prior about that to update
my credences show me a spaceship show me
an alien you know let us go touch it and
do science on it and stuff like that
then I'll be convinced this is no we're
close this is just some dude who likes
attention is a bit of a conspiracy
theorist you know again as I always say
I could be wrong about this but if I
have to bet if I have to think about
what I'm going to do with my life I'm
not putting a lot of uh Credence on
these particular claims and by the way
these claims happen all the time it's
like every six months or every year
there's some new idea that okay this
time we're gonna get the evidence we're
gonna find out and you'll be sorry you
know you being all of us a Skeptics and
I'm like okay
call me up after it happens and I'll
I'll look forward to being sorry and by
the way I will look forward to being
sorry it I will absolutely very very
quickly repent and say not and I will
not claim if if we actually find out
that the government does have
alien crash relics okay if I will not
pretend that I was supportive of that
idea all along I will be completely
wrong if that turns out to be true and
I'll be very very quick to admit that I
was wrong let's just get that in the
record right now meanwhile though let's
uh move on to other AMA questions
Michael lesniak says basketball games
okay now we're talking basketball games
tend to drag out with all the timeouts
curious what your take would be on
handling them the way curling does the
team calling timeout can talk to coaches
and strategize but the other team cannot
unless they also burn a timeout or do
you think that the game is fine just the
way it is you know I think there's two
things going on here one is that the
level of physical exertion involved in
basketball and curling are not really
comparable okay basketball is really
tiring even though you're only you know
the clock is only running for 48 minutes
which is not that long uh you're running
very fast up and down the court that
whole time and you're being smashed into
by other players and there's a high
probability of injury the number of
injuries in the NBA uh in recent years
is is just astonishingly high and very
frustrating to me I don't remember it
being like that back in my day and I'm
not quite sure why they seem to be more
prevalent these days but basketball
players you know the timeouts are not
just to strategize they're to catch your
breath that's kind of an important thing
so I think that you shouldn't change the
general
um feeling of timeouts and what they are
having said that there's just an obvious
problem with NBA games and how they end
right when the games are close there are
various ways for coaches to drag out the
ending of the game to give themselves
some small chance of maybe pulling out a
miracle win you foul the other player
you send them to the free throw line and
then you get the ball back and they can
only shoot twice if you if you fail them
on a two shot foul and then you can try
to make a three-pointer so maybe you can
climb back into the game there have been
suggestions for ways to do it better
there's something called the Elam ending
or Elam I don't know how to pronounce it
but there's also just ways of you know
punishing the team more harshly if they
fell in the last two minutes of the game
right so I would be entirely in favor of
fixing the rules so that the very last
couple minutes of an NBA game don't drag
out that long but the general strategy
the general tenor and tone of timeouts
in the NBA is fine with me we all need a
commercial break for various reasons
right
Nick C says what do you say is the best
or most convincing explanation of the
Copenhagen interpretation that you've
come across and what is the
interpretation of quantum mechanics that
you find most compelling besides
Copenhagen in many worlds so let me be
clear I've tried to be clear before the
Copenhagen interpretation is not an
interpretation it's not a theory it's
not at all respectable it can't be right
there's just it's just not on the table
as a competitor okay it is what most
physicists go along with but that's just
because they're not trying to understand
it very hard and the reason why is not
because the Copenhagen interpretation is
wrong it's just because it's incomplete
it's fuzzy it's vague it's not a theory
it doesn't tell you what happens you
know you say I measure a Quantum system
and its wave function collapses but it
doesn't say what a measurement is it
doesn't say when things collapse it
doesn't say how closely you have to
measure any of those things so it's just
not one of the things that are taken
seriously when it comes to inter found
formulations of quantum mechanics now
there is a sort of post Copenhagen
School of epistemic approaches to
Quantum Mechanics which is to say we
don't treat the wave function as
representing reality we treat it as a
way to make predictions and the
fundamental real things are the agents
The Observers making those predictions
that's more respectable than Copenhagen
it's sort of a gussied up more
respectable looking version of
Copenhagen because Copenhagen also tries
to make some of those moves but I still
don't think they make any sense in their
current state because you haven't told
me what an agent is like what is an
agent that has experiences how do I
model that mathematically that's just
not what I do in physics or in science
more generally I need to be a little bit
more specific a little bit more rigorous
Etc
um so I don't I don't think the
Copenhagen is in the running but the
epistemic approaches are even though I
think they have very very deep problems
themselves in terms of other
interpretations probably something like
Bohemian mechanics is is the next one
after many worlds but honestly it's so
far behind uh that in my personal
ranking that I don't spend any time
thinking about the alternatives to be
honest
Bob zanelli asks a priority question so
remember that ama questioners that is to
say patreon supporters have uh in their
pocket as soon as they Join patreon one
opportunity in their life to ask a
priority question and a priority
question is one that I will do my best
to answer uh the
idea that you can only do it once in
your life is not very harshly enforced
if you want to you know sneak in another
one it's hard for me not to uh it's hard
for me to notice because I'm not really
keeping track so I'm relying on the
honor of the questioners to only ask one
question in their lives
um you know we're at the point now where
I cannot answer every question I feel
bad because some of these priority
questions people clearly very much
wanted to ask the question maybe they
did ask it before and I didn't answer it
and usually when I don't answer a
question it's because I don't have
anything interesting to say and then
they ask it as a priority question and
it still remains true that I don't have
anything interesting to say so I feel
sorry about that sorry anyway Bob's
question is assuming an extreme old
black hole is possible in very general
terms how would its gravity field be
described yeah not that much differently
than a regular black hole to be
perfectly honest there are the idea of
an extremal black hole has to do with
the fact that black holes are
characterized by their Mass
large and spin right and in some sense
not a very exact sense but in some sense
the effect of charge and spin
counteracts the effect of Mass on the
gravitational field of the black hole so
it's easiest if we think about
electrically charged black holes okay so
spin is a whole other thing because then
you're violating spherical Symmetry and
you have to be careful and you can be
but let's think about electrical charge
okay so
the thing that happens when you have an
extremal electrically charged black hole
is imagine that you have two
electrically charged black holes and
they're sitting at some distance away
from each other right so they have a
gravitational pull because they're black
holes so they have gravitational pull
but they also have electrostatic
repulsion if they're both positively
charged for an extremal black hole those
two forces exactly cancel
the two black holes can just sit there
at a constant distance from each other
because they are pulling each other
gravitationally pushing each other apart
electromagnetically and therefore they
don't move
but if you're an uncharged particle if
you are not yourself electrically
charged then you will just fall into the
black hole it's just a black hole as far
as you're concerned you're not being
pushed away from it by any uh Force if
you're just not electrically charged
yourself there's a whole very very
interesting
discourse about extremo black holes
because the interior space-time
structure of extremo black holes is
quite different I once wrote a paper
about this with Matt Johnson and Lisa
Randle
because there's a sort of discontinuity
in the internal space-time structure as
you go from a regular black hole to an
extremal one uh basically what you're
what you're trying to do is Imagine
taking a regular black hole and then
throwing electrical charges into it to
charge it up right but the thing is when
you're throwing electrical charges into
the black hole those electrical charges
are massive particles there's no
massless electrical charges so you're
adding both mass and charge to the black
hole and as far as we know you can't
make an extremo black hole because you
are always adding more mass than charge
in some sense in which you can generally
compare them so if you were able to go
super extreme well if you were able to
imagine a black hole that in some units
once again had more charge than mass
then you could have a naked Singularity
out there in the universe and so that's
a super extremal black hole so extreme
old black hole is kind of on the
boundary it's an unstable thing it's
right barely at the point where there
might be naked Singularity but there
isn't really so it's thought that in
nature you're not going to get any
extremal black holes for that reason but
they're interesting things for theorists
to think about in particular if you're
doing super gravity or super String
Theory there are configurations of uh
supersymmetric extremo black holes where
you can really talk about some of their
properties analytically very nicely so
they're very fun things for theorist to
think about they're not really out there
in nature as far as we know and if you
were just standing next to one you'd
fall into it and then you could not come
out because it's a black hole
Leon B says love the conversation with
Katie Elliott in the last half an hour
or so of your discussion it became clear
to me that she was fishing for something
she found unclear in your philosophy and
was probing to uncover exactly what it
was after her parting shot that's the
saddest thing I've ever heard it
occurred to me that maybe what's missing
is Humanity you have a very well-defined
philosophy of particles but doesn't
philosophy have to say something about
people
well yeah sure philosophy has something
to say about people uh if you read my
book the big picture I talk about people
an awful lot it's a big part of of
things I I think it's got to be
compatible with your philosophy of
particles because people are made of
particles at some simple level right and
I actually don't think that that I agree
with your diagnosis that there is
something that Katie found unclear or
unsatisfying in my perspective but I
don't think it's that people were not
there I think it's more metaphysical
ontological
um and it's a very common difference
like in on the some spectrum of
philosophical views there's very
different various different questions
you can ask yourself philosophically
right so there's a particular question
you can ask yourself about what is the
world made of how many things how many
kinds of things are there out there in
the world how rich is your ontology
versus how sparse and baron is your
ontology there's one point of view which
says like there's lots of different
kinds of things in the world that have
some reality and they all interact
together in certain ways to make up the
world we know there's another point of
view that says the world is basically
one kind of thing and that for our own
personal convenience we subdivide it
into pieces and talk about those pieces
in that particular Continuum I am far on
one side where I think that the world is
just one simple kind of thing and all
the subdivision into pieces Etc is
apparent and effective and useful to us
at a higher level it is emergent it is
not fundamental and I think that that is
what I I think you know we'd have to ask
Katie but I think that is the difference
that she was trying to pinpoint because
I'm really in favor of removing almost
everything from the ontology and then
showing how the stuff that we see in the
world whether it's you know causes and
effects or tables and chairs or free
will or or choice or anything like that
emerges at some higher level and I like
to say it doesn't mean it's not real
it's still real tables and chairs are
real so is Free Will so are causes and
purposes but they're approximate higher
level things we explain in terms of some
deeper level unified thing I think
that's what she was aiming at but you
know we'd already gone on long enough so
uh maybe she'll write a paper about it
and then you know refute all of my
opinions
Liam McCarty says I saw you on
Robinson's podcast with David Albert
David disagreed with you about the many
worlds interpretations saying it wasn't
clear how probability could apply to
branching of the wave function since
each branching event happens only once
you said he needed to get to let go of
the frequentest view of probability
after all we speak of the probability of
a candidate winning an election even
though the election will only happen
once but I've never understood how such
a probability say of a candidate winning
an election makes any sense sure it
expresses a degree of confidence in the
election result but there's no way to
ever know if that confidence was
appropriate since the election happens
only once can you explain how a
non-frequentist view of probability
makes sense yes I can or at least I can
try and then you can decide for yourself
whether it works or not
um I think that your attitude or your
perspective on this Liam is a common one
I think that a lot of people
come across the idea of probability it
gets explained in terms of a frequency
you know what do you mean when you say
the coin is 50 chance of being heads 50
chance of being tails what you mean is
if you did it more and more times it
would Converge on 50 50 right and that
is the objective frequentest view of
probability the subjectivist says
something that is very very different
than that and you can agree with it or
disagree with it it's going to
completely match the coin example in the
simple examples but it is fundamentally
a different kind of thing and so what I
would just say is that you you can't
just secretly or not secretly assume
that what is meant by probability is an
objective frequency
that is one possible thing it could be
but other people mean something else by
it what they mean is a degree of
confidence that something is going to
happen when I have a coin and I'm going
to flip it I don't know anything more
than to say that it's 50 50 heads and
tails okay and I can't flip it an
infinite number of times so the
subjectivist says uh look all this talk
about infinite number of times is just
something you made up to make yourself
feel better in the real world you're
going to flip the coin it's going to be
either heads or tails and the statement
I give it a 50 chance of being heads and
a 50 chance of being tails is nothing
more than a statement of your ignorance
as to which the actual future is going
to be
it fits well with sort of eternalist
perspective on time as as Katie and I
talked about a little bit
um if you think there is actually some
fact about the future and you just don't
yet know it that would be the relevant
feature of the world in the case of the
flipping coin and as subjectivist says
what I mean by saying there's a 50 50
chance is that I will give equal
confidence equal Credence to either one
of those two things happening and I
think that the thing to pinpoint is
where you say
um
uh where is it uh oh yeah
this probability expresses a degree of
confidence in the election result but
there's no way to ever know if that
confidence was appropriate aha so
basically you're you're uh showing us
that you have a pre-existing few view of
probability where it must be objective
that's what appropriate is doing here
like what do you mean appropriate you
mean the right probability but a
subjectivist about probability doesn't
believe that there's no such thing as
the appropriate confidence right there's
the best we can do that's all there is
there is a fact that in some way
the probability of the coin being heads
is either one or zero but we don't know
which one that's the only appropriate
thing to do so we subjectively say it's
50 50. and the subjectivist is going to
say that's no different than saying
who's going to win the election who's
going to win the NBA championship which
branch of the wave function I'm going to
end up on there's a bunch of things that
happen and I this is why I like the
which branch of the wave function I'm
going to end up on right because that's
clearly a mis-stated idea because I'm
not going to end up on one branch of the
wave function or another there will be a
version of me that ends up on one and a
version of me that ends up on the other
so there's no objective probability
there's no frequentest probability that
you can assign to that all you can do is
say once I'm in that state that you know
I've measured a particle it's either
spin up or spin down I don't know which
one it is yet what is the probability
what is the Credence that I put on being
one branch or the other that's an
intrinsically subjective thing and I can
make arguments based on rational
uh pushing around of those credences
that says I'd better use the born rule
to do it
but this is a fundamental psychological
barrier people who think that
probabilities must be objective are not
going to be happy with the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics all
my all I'm saying is that there's a
whole bunch of things that they're not
going to be happy with in which we use
probabilities all the time like go to
the internet you can find the odds about
who's gonna win the Super Bowl that's a
statement of probability even though
it's only going to happen once
Paul torreck says oh another one about
the same podcast when you and David
Albert went on Robinson's podcast David
mentioned self-locating uncertainty as a
guide to Quantum probabilities he gave a
thought experiment involving Captain
Kirk using a transporter that splits him
into two people one wearing green and
one blue and before Kirk can see his
clothing he attaches some probability to
Green you then talked about betting odds
and wound up supposing that the two
resulting Kirks share One bank account
do they have to share some reward like a
bank account isn't the point rather that
the one that the one Kirk anticipating
having transported and the two after
must all share the same probabilities
since the brain processes that lead to
their credences are identical and the
only probability that makes sense in
that context is 50 50.
well I think yeah you stated the issue
clearly and correctly but I think that
there's two different issues going on
here okay one is the one that you're
getting at is what could the probability
possibly be other than 50 50 and there's
there's no sensible thing that it could
be other than 50 50. there's no rational
decision procedure or way of thinking
that says in this
um experiment by the way so the
experiment is you know Captain Kirk is
uh put in the transporter machine but
it's a malfunctioning transporter
machine that makes two copies of you
right so it's just the the duplication
machine and in one copy you know Kirk is
wearing a blue shirt the other one some
green shirt and so what should the
probabilities be like you say it's
exactly identical it should be 50 50
right but there's no possible way that
you would ever get to 90 10 and really
defend oh yes it's definitely 90 green
that makes no sense but that's not David
Albert's objection his objection is not
that it should be 90 10 rather than 50
50. his objection is that you shouldn't
assign probabilities at all you should
just remain silent you should follow
Professor wittgenstein's advice this is
something about which we cannot speak so
we should just remain silent about it
okay I don't agree with that at all I
think that that's a not a good way to go
through life if you are going to you
know wake up after this experiment and
either have the green church or the blue
shirt or whatever
it is part of your attempt to cope with
the world around you to assign credences
to the different possibilities you know
I can say if I climb out the window and
jump I just don't know whether I will
fall up or float in the air who knows
that's asking me a question about how
the fundamental laws of physics work and
I'm not sure so I can't possibly be
expected to assign a Credence right No
One Believes that by the way no one
actually thinks that way my point is you
should think that way if you logically
are bound to think that way if you think
that you cannot assign probabilities in
these duplication processes it's in both
cases a subjective probability about a
case where
there's you know objectively something's
going to happen you don't know what it
is for sure you are basically required
as a functioning human being to have a
Credence in the different possibilities
you have a Credence and whether or not
you're gonna float in the air or fall
down if you jump out a window right that
Credence is not a frequency
We're Not Gonna you know change the laws
of physics many many times laws of
physics are what they are that
particular event only happens once but
you can get evidence for it by doing
other experiments
um it's a tricky thing I don't wanna you
know I I disagree with David about this
this is a central point of our
disagreements even though we agree with
many many things
um but I it's not a silly argument his
argument makes perfect sense uh it's
it's one that I don't agree with but I
can see why someone would feel that way
because the situation is quite different
than what we're used to we're we're used
to situations we feel comfortable in
situations where what we mean by
probability is some borrowed version of
a frequency right when you're flipping
coins or playing dice or playing cards
then you can really imagine doing the
experiment in infinite number of times
get a frequency these kinds of things
where you can't imagine doing the
experiment if a number of times you get
a frequency therefore bother people my
response is that you never really were
doing an infinite number of times you
were always attaching a Credence to it
you gotta do your best to come up with
the Credence that makes logical sense to
you
Anonymous says if we look at the global
economy as a complex system can we see
it functioning so that each individual
person could spend continually less
working time to meet his or her needs
say according to Maslow
well this sounds like a very complicated
question about the function of the
global economy but I do think personally
that yeah I mean it's pretty darn clear
that we are in a situation where we
generate a lot of wealth in the world
and it is not spread out of anything
like equally right or evenly uh we could
lift a whole bunch of people out of
poverty
the question is whether but sorry by
spreading around the wealth more equally
I think that's perfectly clear the
question is whether or not that is a net
good thing to do because the argument
the counter argument is twofold number
one there is a sort of results-oriented
argument that says that the existences
of inequality are important
for making progress yes not everyone
benefits but the people who do benefit
benefit so much and there's so many of
them that it's still worth it that's one
attitude the other is just a more moral
based argument that says that you know
people have the right to keep what they
earn and things like that
um but anyway I do this is this I'm
you're you're uh generating answers to a
different question than what you asked
so I should come back to the question
you're asking I do think that it makes
no sense that we have so many people in
the world who are so poor let's put it
that way I think we could do much better
than we actually do
could each individual person continually
spend less working time to meet his or
her needs I think that just depends a
lot on what you mean by the needs right
um I didn't need to have the internet
100 years ago do I need to have the
internet now well I don't need it you
don't need to be listening to this
podcast what do you mean by need right
um as the world changes the things that
we want and the things that we might
reasonably aspire to change with them
life expectancies were a lot shorter 100
years ago and now we might reasonably
expect to get decent Healthcare that
carries us through ordinary medical
circumstances we don't always achieve
that right I do think that we're just
building computers building robots
building manufacturing that lets us
produce a lot more stuff so if you keep
the amount of stuff everyone has
constant the amount of work everyone has
to do will go down but almost no one
wants to do that right maybe some people
do but most people want more stuff and
that that doesn't sound I mean it sounds
worse than it is some of the stuff we
want is just like healthy food and you
know long life and health care and the
ability to talk to our friends and have
fun and stuff like that these are good
things to want uh let me put it this way
I think that the world is changing very
rapidly and our cognitive setup the way
that we think as human beings is trained
on conditions from a thousand years ago
or five thousand years ago and I don't
think that we have done a very good job
in setting up the global economy in the
best possible way given our current
capacities uh I don't know necessarily
what the best way to do it is but I
think that this is something where it's
just hard to do the right thing because
a lot of people don't know what the
right thing is they don't even agree on
what it is if they do think that they
know it they can't uh figure out ways to
work together to make it happen some
people don't want the right thing to
happen because they benefit from the
wrong thing happening it's a complicated
mess so I would like to move toward I
did a we did a podcast with John danher
about this the the possibility of an
automated Utopia where people could just
stop working and enjoy life and be
creative and so forth and I don't think
that's what will happen in the
medium-term future but it's something
that we can at least talk about now in a
way that we couldn't talk about 200
years ago
Brent Meeker says Roy Kerr claims that
penrose's Singularity theorem for black
holes doesn't actually apply to the real
world he says that there's a spinning
object at the center of a black hole he
points out that the solutions that
describe black holes are vacuum
Solutions and so a vacuum is just
assumed they are not solutions for
collapse of real bodies are there any
solutions even computational ones for
the collapse of matter into a spinning
black hole do they treat the matter
Quantum mechanically
I think that penrose's Singularity
theorems are the wrong thing to talk
about in this context the whole point of
the singularity theorems is they don't
assume spherical symmetry they don't
assume vacuum or anything like that
they're quite generic they assume what
are called Energy conditions which means
that there are certain kinds of energy
and momentum that you're not allowed to
consider basically negative energy
energy right negative Mass repulsive
gravity if you could have repulsive
gravity negative masses then you would
not need to have a singularity you could
just throw a bunch of negative energy
into the black hole and prevent The
Singularity from happening but the whole
point of the singularity theorems
otherwise is that they are otherwise
completely generic they do not assume
any symmetries or anything like that
before the singularity theorems came
along you could very well have worried
that singularities you predict in
gravitational Collapse by the way Robert
oppenheimer's most famous physics work
was exact on this but anyway those
gravitational collapses that we could
understand analytically were all
spherically symmetric and maybe the
singularities were just an artifact of
that the whole point of Singularity
theorems to say no even if you look at
more General situations uh different
things happen
now if you want to know exactly what
does happen that's harder okay so the
singularity theorem say that as long as
you have certain energy conditions being
obeyed then you will get a singularity
they don't tell you how you get a
singularity they don't tell you what
kind of Singularity you have the Cur
solution Roy Kerr for those who don't
know was the guy who wrote down the
first exact solution to a spinning black
hole the kermetric and outside of the
spinning black hole the curb metric is
very close to being exactly right inside
it predicts singularities but weird
singularities it also predicts like
wormholes that go to other universes and
things like that things that almost no
physicists think actually are there
because they're not realistic Solutions
describing the formation of a black hole
they are solutions describing a black
hole that was always there with no
matter in it okay when you do have
spinning matter matter with non-zero
angular momentum that collapses to a
black hole the situation is way more
complicated there are computational
attempts at understanding it but
you don't know exactly things go crazy
and it's hard to know how reliable they
are
do they treat the matter Quantum
mechanically well what do you mean by
Quantum mechanically
um do you mean you have a wave function
you're doing quantum gravity or do you
just mean that the energy and pressure
are compatible with more quantum
mechanical constraints I'm not sure I'm
not a super expert on this I do know
that the quest to understand
exactly what happens when realistic
things collapse to make black holes is
an ongoing one it's not a settled uh
field right now there is a sort of
consensus as to what happens which is
that you collapse to a singularity
in a real world spinning black hole but
you know until you know for sure you
don't know for sure
Paul Conte says assuming that University
level textbooks in general reach a
smaller number of readers do you think
it would be better to write more popular
science books which I imagine reach a
larger audience readership do you prefer
writing popular science or textbooks for
students
you know you're not going to be
surprised at my answer here which is
that you should do both I am always a
believer in a wide pluralistic ecosystem
of attempts to talk about science to
teach science to educate people about
science there's absolutely a very
obvious good reason to write textbooks
which is that even if you reach a
smaller readership that readership is
very important it's the readership that
will grow up to become professional
physicists and do new physics right so
that's a important thing you can do for
the world I'm always very very tickled
when I see people who are now doing
great things to you know Finding
gravitational waves or something like
that and they say they learned general
relativity from my textbook you know
that tells me I did something worthwhile
for the world but it's also very very
important to write popular level things
like you say you reach a larger
readership that readership might be
mostly interested in simply
understanding things or or increasing
their knowledge about the universe for
the their personal reasons rather than
for future contributions to science but
that's entirely okay I'm very much in
favor of that I think that the same
thing goes for different media whether
it's books or podcasts or blog posts or
lectures or TV shows or movies or
whatever do it every single possible way
that you can do it
um I think they're all different ways of
reaching different kinds of audiences in
terms of preference you know I don't
know about preference I you get
different rewards from writing a good
textbook versus writing a good popular
book so it's a tie let me let me cop out
by saying that
Kevin Harang says I learned a lot from
your recent discussion about artificial
intelligence with Rafael miliere thank
you but I'm still wondering where you
personally come down on the question of
whether current or future iterations of
AI or something to be worried about like
Einstein warned about nuclear technology
either intrinsically or just in the
wrong hands
yeah sure you should definitely be
worried the question is what is the form
that that worry takes uh I thought that
you know the open letter that said stop
doing research on AI for six months
while we figure out what to do was as a
practical matter completely unrealistic
for various reasons number one how are
you going to get everyone in the world
to agree to stop doing that what's to
stop people from actually continuing AI
research just not tell anybody about it
right especially people in other
countries or whatever number two you
know what in the world makes you think
that in six months you'll figure out
what to do about it I think it's a
misunderstanding of how these things
work these things are processes that are
ongoing both the process of developing
Ai and the process of developing
safeguards and figuring out what to do
about it the the the the open letter did
a lot of good in the sense that it you
know sort of got people talking about
the issue which is great but I don't
think it actually what it was asking for
was the right thing to ask for the the
right thing to ask for is
very accelerated hard thinking and
policy implementation of safeguards that
would protect us from the worst aspects
of AI what those aspects could be
there's obvious many choices like if you
turn over important technological or
industrial features to control by
computers rather than humans you open up
the possibility of disastrous errors
humans using AI to spread misinformation
and fake news and so forth is an obvious
big problem so I think it is it's very
very important to put safeguards in to
think about what the safeguards are that
we need I I didn't really like the idea
of just pausing research for six months
I also don't like the idea of
emphasizing the I the the possibility of
existential risk where you kill every
human being on earth that is absolutely
possible but it's sufficiently low
probability that I don't think that it's
the right way to think about it I think
that if you you will actually increase
the chances of bad things happening if
that's the kind of risk you worry about
rather than the real very very uh
imminent risks that we have from Ai and
and furthermore if you worry about the
imminent risks you're much more likely
to also ameliorate the existential risks
so that's what I would be in favor of
doing
I'm going to group two questions
together one is from yaspi or nagra
saying leaving aside the provocative
name does Conway's Free Will theorem
prove anything stronger about hidden
variable theories than Bells
and then Kyle Hicks says I've heard
Roger Penrose State something to the
effect of the superposition of the wave
function makes the geometry of
space-time unstable which causes
collapse of the wave function even
proposing that the time of collapse can
be predicted by the formula T equals H
planks constant divided by the
gravitational energy could you explain
why he would believe that space-time
could become unstable and your general
thoughts on the Doshi Penrose model
you might be wondering why I'm grouping
these two questions together they're
both about quantum mechanics but
otherwise they're very different it's
because I wanted to say something I've
said it before but I maybe you know I
got to keep saying it different people
are listening I am not an expert on
other theories of quantum mechanics and
the foundations of quantum mechanics in
general uh you know the foundations of
quantum mechanics is one of my
specialties if you like look up my CV
it's one of the things I do for a living
but what I mean by that is I investigate
the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics and in particular what
that has to say about other areas of
physics whether it's quantum gravity or
field Theory or whatever because I
personally think that many worlds is
much more likely to be true than any of
the other ones as I always say I would
love to be wrong it'd be cool and then I
would change my mind that would be great
but yet only have a finite number of
heartbeats right every human being has
on average three billion heartbeats in
their life you have to allocate your
heartbeats you have to allocate the time
you have on Earth to think about these
questions if you're a scientist if
you're a researcher
there are literally an infinite number
of research questions that you could
devote yourself to you have to pick the
ones you think are going to be most
productive so I actually don't spend any
serious time thinking about other
approaches to quantum mechanics and this
is all by way a preamble of saying that
I'm not going to get very satisfying
answers to these two questions so
yosphere's questions is about Conway's
Free Will theorem the one thing I can
say about this is a terrible name
everyone agrees it's a terrible name has
nothing to do with free will if you're
not if you don't know what this is this
is a theorem that was proved a couple
years ago perfectly valid result in
Quantum foundations and it has to do
with the fact that you know it's one of
these theorems like Bell's theorem
that tries to make statements that are
independent of a particular picture of
quantum foundations so rather than
saying let's work within this picture or
some other picture it says imagine the
following axioms hold then what can we
conclude about that right so Bell's
theorem assumes that you have uh
definite measurement outcomes various
other kinds of things the Free Will
theorem is basically that says under
certain very reasonable assumptions
there will be a case where you cannot
predict the spin of the electron it is
indeterministic it is not deterministic
okay under certain very
reasonable sounding assumptions you know
no signals traveling faster than the
speed of light and and so forth so this
seems very very unsurprising if you know
about quantum mechanics quantum
mechanics already says that you can't
predict the outcome of an experiment
completely deterministically the Free
Will theorem which is Conway and also
um uh cooking I think uh they say that
well okay we don't need to assume
quantum mechanics we're assuming these
weaker principles and you can derive the
fact that physics will not be
deterministic they called it free will
rather than indeterminism just for PR
purposes it has literally nothing to do
with free will it's just saying that
certain aspects of physics are
indeterministic which if you believe in
quantum mechanics already you already
knew is true so just like Belle's
theorem these kinds of theorems are
constraints on Alternatives you could
maybe imagine
someday developing two conventional
quantum mechanics
but for me I'm not looking for an
alternative to Conventional quantum
mechanics I like conventional quantum
mechanics I'm sticking with that
likewise for Kyle's question about
penrose's model Penrose violates
conventional quantum mechanics he has an
objective collapse model the most
popular objective collapse models in
Quantum Foundation circles are the
spontaneous collapse models where wave
functions just have a certain
probability of collapsing all by
themselves for no good reason whereas
penrose's model is in the vein of what
you might call triggered or induced
collapses when a certain condition is
met the wave function collapses and that
condition in penrose's version has
something to do with gravity
that's all I know about it I don't know
anything else about it for all the
reasons that are conventionally put
forward
um I don't love the violence being done
to the Schrodinger equation by saying
that wave functions truly collapse for
occasional purposes
um nor do I think that gravity should
play a role in the understanding of
quantum mechanics at a deep level and
now I understand I don't hold that
latter point of view quite as strongly
as some of my friends because some
people are like well look when I talk
about the simple harmonic oscillator or
two spins or whatever gravity is not
involved I don't need gravity to talk
about quantum mechanics and I do think
it's perfectly fair for Penrose to
respond to that by saying what I care
about is the real world and in the real
world there is both gravity and quantum
mechanics so I'm perfectly allowed to
use gravity to help me understand the
mysteries of quantum mechanics I'm
sympathetic to that prospective argument
that Penrose could put forward but I
don't think that as a matter of fact
gravity is anything do with quantum
mechanics at the fundamental level
Aaron Bowden says I found Joe Silk's
Moon science argument compelling would
you go to the Moon if you had an
opportunity to work there for say a
six-month mission
you know I think this depends a lot on
what my Credence was that it would be
safe to go to the Moon I would love to
go you know that would be a lot of fun
right just for a touristy Mission not
for a one-way trip as if I thought I was
going to come back the question right
now is that space travel is certainly
not safe uh there's a certain fraction
of the time when you have a disaster and
people die and that fraction is
uncomfortably large I think you know one
way to put it is if I thought that
chance of a fatal accident was 10 to the
minus 4 then I would go if it I thought
it was 10 to the minus 1 then I would
not somewhere in between it would be a
difficult decision but of course it
would depend a lot therefore on exactly
who was flying what their track record
was and so forth
Oleg rivinsky says I've recently read
your new paper on discretizing quantum
mechanics yeah so by the way I put a
couple of papers on the archive uh
lately one was one on they're very
completely different one was with my old
grad school advisor George field on
making primordial magnetic fields from
Axion Dynamics and the other one was
from uh just me on discretizing quantum
mechanics so the idea here is that
we talk a lot about discrete space time
right but even if space-time is discreet
if you believe in quantum mechanics the
theory the fundamental scientific theory
that you're working with is not discrete
because it's quantum mechanics quantum
mechanics is not a discrete Theory the
elements of the theory are vectors in
Hilbert space and Vector spaces like
helperspace are smooth they are not
discrete the space of states is in no
sense discrete in quantum mechanics and
furthermore there is smooth time
Evolution according to the Schrodinger
equation so I asked myself the question
is it possible to discretize Hilbert
space in a way that is naturally
compatible with the Schrodinger equation
a couple other people have already asked
about whether you could discretize
helper space at all and they said yes
but I specifically said you know could
you do it in a way compatible with the
Schrodinger equation and I said yes you
can but there's problems with doing it
it does get rid of infinity in the sense
of an infinite number of states but the
universe still lasts eternally even if
time steps are discrete according to the
evolution and so you get recurrences so
you'll find a number of things that can
happen but they happen infinitely often
and so you get all the problems that you
would normally get with boltzmann brains
and things like that so anyway you can
look it up on archive if you want so
Oleg asks
um
I also recently read another paper the
board a guthful Lincoln theorem and
extended the sitter spaces which if I
understand correctly states that the
universe is geodesically complete I.E
had to have a beginning I wonder whether
there's a contradiction here between
these models or are they compatible so
I'm using this I have not read this
paper that Oleg is pointing to the
Bordeaux youthful Lincoln theorem and
extended to sitter spaces but I'll use
it as an excuse to talk about the
Bordeaux youthful Lincoln theorem in
general
borde guthin are top-notch theoretical
cosmologists you should believe what
they say but what they do is they prove
a theorem about certain kinds of
classical space time and all the words
here matter they make some assumptions
they say if the following things are
true then the following things follow
and the thing that they're proving a
theorem about is classical space time
now some people want to pretend that
they're not proving ethereum about
classical space time because when you
think about the difference between
quantum mechanics and classical
mechanics Linux there's two differences
there's many differences but two are
relevant here one is that you are
talking about a different kind of thing
right if you have a point particle in
classical mechanics that has a location
and a momentum and that's its state and
you can predict its future if you're
doing quantum mechanics you're talking
about a wave function of that particle
that's a completely different kind of
thing likewise if you're doing gravity
you have classical space time if you do
quantum gravity you have a wave function
of space-time a completely different
kind of thing the sep that second
ingredient is you have specific
equations of motion that tell us how
those things that you're studying evolve
with time Newton's equations or
Hamilton's equations or the Euler
LaGrange equations there's a separate
set of equivalent ways of talking about
classical equations of motion
likewise there is the Schrodinger
equation or the Heisenberg equation of
motion or the Feynman path integral
these are distinct equivalent ways of
talking about the quantum motion and the
board of guthful Lincoln do not assume
classical equations of motion
so some people say Well they're not
really doing classical space time but
the space time is completely classical
they've changed their they've thrown out
the equations they're not assuming any
certain equations about it but they're
still looking at classical space time
and what they're saying is
certain kinds of classical space time
under certain assumptions have a
singularity in the past so what do we
learn from saying that can we say that
the Universe therefore had a beginning
no of course not there's no version of
the borde Guth will Lincoln theorem that
implies the universe had a beginning I'm
not sure how to say this more clearly
for two obvious reasons number one their
assumptions might be wrong there are
plenty of examples on the market of
universes that don't have a beginning
models of universes that don't have a
beginning they're all completely
compatible with the Border youthful
Lincoln theorem because they don't fit
the assumptions that it makes but the
second and more conceptually important
thing is space time is not a classical
thing we have quantum gravity so you
cannot possibly learn anything
fundamentally necessarily true about the
real world by looking at the board day
Guth will Lincoln theorem or any of its
generalizations what you learn when you
look at a theorem whether it's penrose's
Singularity theorems or the bgv theorem
is that there is a singularity in this
classical space time and how to
interpret that is to say that our
understanding gives out our ability to
think of space-time as classical ends at
this point it says nothing at all about
the universe ending or coming into
existence or having a beginning or
anything like that it's just about the
applicability of the classical
approximation
so therefore no there's no
incompatibility whatsoever my paper on
quantum mechanics was about Quantum
states that evolve eternally with time
that is completely compatible with
anything that you might want to argue
about classical space times I mean the
question is does a certain model of
quantum mechanics that is to say a
certain hamiltonian Etc reproduce this
particular Behavior or not that I don't
know but there's no in principle
incompatibility there
by the way I said the bgv theorem is
perfectly respectable scientific theorem
if you look at who cites it in the
literature it's almost all religious
people it's almost all people arguing
for the beginning of the universe
because they want to prove the existence
of God scientists know that it's an
interesting theorem but just not that
Central because the universe is
fundamentally Quantum not classical
Craig Hooper says what do people mean
when they say the universe is infinite
do they think it's do you think it's
infinite I'm with Gen 11 in the we've
never encountered any physical quantity
to this infinite Camp so it seems
unlikely to me that there is one
quantity like diameter or volume that is
the exception
well I don't know about that particular
argument uh we've never encountered any
physical quantity that is infinite how
would you know whether you did on the
real number line there's an infinite
number of points between zero and one
but if you actually draw a line segment
on a piece of paper in front of you you
can't tell whether there's some
discretization and there's really only a
finite number of points or whether it's
an infinite number of points so my
attitude is let it I don't know we let
it be either way we don't have any way
of telling right now there are I don't
want to underplay the the importance of
the question that's why I wrote this
paper I was just talking about because
maybe you can help resolve some
conceptual mathematical philosophical
puzzles if you don't need to invoke
Infinity when you talk about the
physical universe and in quantum
mechanics standard quantum mechanics you
do need to invoke Infinity so I wrote a
little paper saying here's a version of
quantum mechanics where you don't but
again it's all toward the purpose of
keeping an open mind about whether
Infinity really does exist or not I just
don't know
Giorgio says the professor I work for to
achieve my Master's Degree has high
Ambitions and a broad spectrum of
knowledge he chooses his students based
on potential and their motivation and he
gives them gives us complete freedom in
our research do you also prefer this
Long Leash approach with your students
or do you prefer a short of more
hand-holding approach
well I think something in between I'm
not very hand-holdy that is true
um just because I'm stretched too thinly
I'm doing too many things I'm working
with several different students I have a
podcast that you might know about I
write books I teach you know I do
various different things so it's I am
not the kind of advisor who is working
on the students problem just as hard as
they are I know that there are such
advisors and I admire them
um but I just don't have time to do that
and I try to tell prospective students
exactly that that I'm very good at
coming up with ideas the ideas aren't
always very good ones I'm very good at
coming up with them so they'll never be
a point in our relationship where I say
yeah geez I don't know I'm not sure what
to work on I have no good ideas I have
too many things I want to work on and
I'm very happy to share them with
students but when I do the student is
going to be much better off if they can
take some initiative uh we'll talk you
know regularly and we'll try to bounce
ideas back and forth and we'll both do
calculations but the student is going to
do much of the heavy lifting if a
student wants to do just work on their
own ideas that's great I'm perfectly
happy to do that but most students don't
want to do that at least they don't want
to exclusively do that or they don't
want to do that in the beginning when
you just start out as a graduate student
one of the most useful things that an
advisor can do for you is not just give
you ideas to work on but help you
understand which ideas are promising
worth following up on Etc it's a real
art form choosing not just to do some
projects some calculation or whatever
but also to do the right ones to the
ones that are worth doing so you know
generally speaking graduate students
appreciate this either implicitly or
explicitly so they they want to talk to
the advisor about what are good things
to work on and I'm very happy to do that
you know I'm still new here at Johns
Hopkins so I haven't built up a group
like I used to have at Chicago and then
in Caltech where I was having four or
five grad students at once or more and
they could work together and talk to
each other but we're going to get there
we're working toward that goal
Jan or Yan I'm not sure M says in the
past you you gave several talks about
religious beliefs and even had public
debates with apologists which I find
very interesting however in the last few
years talks and debates from you about
this topic became quite rare as far as I
can tell do you still think that
engaging in these debates is worthwhile
activity for you and if not what has
changed your mind
well I think two things have changed
number one I've kind of said most of
what I have to say you know that there's
a segment of people who enjoy and
participate in either debates or uh
public speaking more broadly
for the intrinsic thrill of it right
because they actually enjoy that they
enjoy getting up there and matching wits
with someone they disagree with that's
really not what I'm about to be honest
that's why on the podcast I have people
who I disagree with sometimes but I'm
really about learning from them I'm not
really about debating them it's just a
personal style thing sometimes debates
are useful I know that other you know
there's other people on the other side
that I don't quite agree with who say
like ah debates are a waste of time
because that's not how real intellectual
work gets done and it's certainly true
that real intellectual work is not
getting done in the debates they're more
about entertainment but also about
inspiration and information you can
reach audiences by doing a debate that
maybe you couldn't reach otherwise but
I've done them you know I've said what I
have to say they can find those debates
on YouTube I think I would just be
repeating myself
but the other thing is they're just not
that many of them like I I have never
been the person to suggest doing a
debate with a religious person or about
some topic like that they've always come
to me or some intermediary has come to
me to set it up and that doesn't happen
that much anymore I think just because
that whole genre has faded away a little
bit it's not just me most people have
said what they've wanted to say uh it's
not doesn't seem to be a lot of
hankering as far as I can tell for new
material along those lines perfectly
okay with me I have plenty of other
things to talk about I'm not running out
anytime soon
says we know we don't live in
anti-disitter space or so I understand
assuming that's correct can you help
shed light on what we hope to gain from
ads CFT Theory uh you know sure very
briefly it's a lamp post you know the
old joke about looking for your keys
under the under the lamp post even
though it's not why you drop them it's
supposed to be a joke because of course
if you drop your keys someplace you
should look for your keys there but if
you have a lamp post do you at least
have a chance of finding your keys
because you can see where they are right
so it's not a completely insane strategy
there's something to be said for the
drunk guy looking for his keys under the
Lamppost
ads CFT is not the real world but it is
a model that we understand much better
than any model that does approximate the
real world so I personally don't do a
lot on ads cfd written a couple papers
along those lines but I prefer to spend
my time working on ideas that are closer
to the real world even if they are less
well-defined more speculative and so
forth other people are going to say no
let me work on a Model that I understand
maybe I will gain some insight that down
the road will be of applicability to the
real world this does you know intersect
with something I said in the solo
episode on the crisis in physics one of
the very legitimate critiques of modern
theoretical physics especially in the
string theory side of things is they're
too willing to say someday this will be
relevant to the real world even though
not now you know that's a perfectly good
status but
tell me when you're gonna get there or
at least you know remember that getting
there is the important thing it's the
real world that ultimately matters and I
think that
it's kind of it's kind of sad that you
can get as far as you can and make a
whole career without making much contact
with the real world so I get I think
it's perfectly legitimate reason to work
on ads cfd I just think that it should
be part of a broader portfolio it can't
be what everyone focuses on
I'm not pronouncing your name very well
girolamo castaldo says I heard you
mentioned at least a couple of times the
geiger counter as an example of quantum
effects influencing the macroscopic
world would you mind elaborating on that
sure the Guyer counter is a Quantum
measurement device because it measures
the decay of a radioactive particle it
clicks when a particle has been emitted
by radioactive substance that
nucleus or whatever the particle was
that was doing the decaying has a wave
function that wave function is typically
in a superposition of I've decayed and
I've not decayed and the geiger counter
performs a Quantum measurement so it
collapses that wave function or at least
apparently collapses it and so if you do
anything in response to what the geiger
counter is doing than in some very real
sense you are responding to a
measurement of a Quantum State you have
Amplified a Quantum superposition to a
real life superposition the real life
superposition is the geiger counter
clicked and it is not clicked right so
that's why Schrodinger when he invented
the Schrodinger's cat thought experiment
had a geiger counter-like thing as part
of it it's just a way of measuring a
Quantum system in a very straightforward
familiar way
Andrew Goldstein says consequences of
climate change continue outpacing
computer-generated weather forecasts
wouldn't computer models be more
accurate if fudge factors were included
to account for consistent underestimates
well I want to say yes and no here I
mean the first thing I want to say the
zero thing is I'm not a climate
scientist I'm not going to second guess
what they're doing it's a very very hard
problem to work on very non-linear many
many aspects coming in and the
measurements are hard to do et cetera
Etc okay so you should really talk to a
real climate scientist not to me about
this but there's two things going on
you're right that in the last few
decades the amount of temperature
variation that we've seen Etc has
generally been more than was predicted
by typical models so there's two things
you can try to do one is you can just
say okay if every time that I try to
make a prediction the real result is 1.2
times the prediction that I'm going to
make I'm just going to multiply my
prediction by 1.2 and make that my
prediction
I get why you would want to do that the
problem is that these models aren't just
best guesses they're models they're
trying to actually model the underlying
Dynamics you can't just multiply by some
fudge factor and declare a victory you
have to understand why you released your
goal is to understand why the actual
readings are coming out on top of your
predictions ahead of time so it would be
much more respectable to dig into the
simulations and figure out why the
effects are bigger than what you
predicted the other thing is though you
might want to as a policy maker rather
than as a scientist you might want to
plan for the future and then you might
want to take into account that over the
last several years or whatever the
models have been underestimating the
effects in that case it's perfectly
legit to say you know the models have
been traditionally under predicting the
size of the effect therefore I'm going
to play it safe and and boost a little
bit so I think it's the difference
between being a modeler who's doing
their best to understanding what all the
effects are and to put them into their
computer code or whatever and make the
best prediction they can versus a policy
maker or a predictor of the future where
you can be more phenomenological about
it and say well given the track record
so far I'm going to predict the
following thing in the future there's no
reason why you couldn't do both
depending on what hat you're wearing at
any one particular time
bits plus atoms says was it a difficult
decision to go on to the Joe Rogan show
do you worry that having a reputable
scientist like yourself on the program
Casa halo over other less reputable
guests is the audience reached too good
to pass up
you know it's a complicated question I
was on The Joe Rogan show you have to
remember it was years ago it was
pre-pandemic okay I have not been on in
a long time and I do think that the show
has steered much more towards uh even
more let's put it that way towards
conspiracy theories and things like that
since the pandemic has hit so I think
it'll be a much more difficult decision
now
um but it in general even if that's true
it's still a difficult decision it's not
it's it's a little bit easy to be overly
moralistic about it but I think that
there's a lot of factors that should go
into thinking about something like this
um one is it's really important to reach
audiences that you can't otherwise reach
it's not just the audience is Big it's
that it's a different audience and if
you say well you know they're just
hearing from all these crackpots isn't
if you're really on the side of these
people who are listening getting the
best information shouldn't some good
people go on too
I don't know I mean I'm just raising the
issue I'm not giving you the answer
because I do think that yeah you can
also lend your credibility to an
operation uh if it's not clear what is
going on but
um maybe you can combat that by being
very clear where you stand uh you know
we just when I was on uh Rogan we we
talked about pretty straightforward
questions about quantum mechanics and
things like that nothing controversial
or conspiracy centered if I ever went on
again I think that I would if which I
don't know I've not been invited uh I'm
not contemplating it anytime soon so
it's completely hypothetical but I would
absolutely want to talk about what I
consider to be an anti-science attitude
in the conspiracy theories the
anti-vaccination stances things like
that that we've seen on the show since
then uh having said that I'm not a
listener of the show so maybe there's a
whole bunch of things going on that I'm
just not aware of
Moshe fader says imagine that your novel
definitive proof of many worlds has won
a Nobel Prize you decide to indulge
yourself by using a fraction of the new
spare cash for three timepieces a dress
watch a sports watch and an over-the-top
weird or technically dazzling watch
which three watches do you pick and why
oh this is a good question because it's
never going to happen I am neither the
Nobel Prize nor the spending all that
money on watches I do uh I am a fan of
mechanical wrist watches this is an
outgrowth of the first trade book that I
wrote from eternity here about the arrow
of time where you know when you write
your first book uh you never know
whether you're going to write another
ones you try to pack everything in so I
tried to talk a little bit about
everything having to do with the idea of
time in one book which that's a lot of
stuff so it's a lot of stuff in the book
and I discovered I hadn't really
followed the whole thing many people
haven't but you know the idea of making
a functioning wrist watch is quite a
technological challenge right you know
there's the whole latitude sorry
longitude issue that was the subject of
prizes back in the day of sailing and so
forth and John Harrison eventually won
the prize so
a mechanical wristwatch that is to say
not a quartz battery-powered wristwatch
but a little machine with gears and
springs and things like that that
accurately keeps time is quite a
marvelous kind of thing and when you dig
into it you realize uh there's a lot of
history and Artisan ship going on and
plus there is this whole historical
event called the quartz crisis where you
know like in the 1950s the only watches
were mechanical watches and they figured
out how to make quartz wrist watches and
basically the whole Swiss mechanical
watch industry essentially collapsed and
it's not mostly I mean to the to some
extent it is but most of these watches
are not like mass produced you know
there's a lot of actual human effort
that goes into them and and know-how
that is easily lost like just like we
used to be able to put people on the
moon and now we've forgotten how to do
that a lot of this wristwatch making
knowledge was not really passed down
from generation to generation so there's
a famous story for example
um Zenith I guess it looks like Zenith
but it's a Swiss company so pronounce it
differently
um
they had a very famous movement as it is
called for a chronograph the el primero
movement the first automatic status to
say self-winding mass-produced or
popularly produced chronograph and they
had you know a particular machine that
was clearly necessary in the
construction of these chronographs which
were you know famous and historic and so
forth and in the 70s the the word came
down from the owners of the company yeah
just throw all that stuff out we don't
use that anymore we're making Chris
quartz watches from now on and one of
the old-timers basically hid the the
plans and the Machine you know in a room
where they couldn't be found and then
what 10 20 years later whenever it was
the whole Swiss watch industry realized
oh my goodness we can Rebrand ourselves
as a luxury good and now we want to re
cover all this knowledge we had and they
were able to pull the machines out of
the mothballs
so I I love all that stuff I think it's
great and I love you know wearing real
wrist watches I don't wear like a smart
watch or anything like that the bad news
is and and I should say it's like quite
a hobby right so there are people
they're you know there they get together
they have uh message boards on the
internet and magazines and whatever okay
so it's fun and I like it the problem is
it costs money and you quickly realize
that it costs too much money and so like
I'm not going to be a player in this
game really it's much more sensible to
look at pictures of wrist watches on the
internet than to actually buy them all
so I have a collection of several
different kinds but um they're not like
the super duper fancy kinds because
those are those are beyond my budget so
I like this idea that I would get The
Nobel Prize and and blow all the money
on wrist watches but I don't have good
answers to well I don't have a good
answer to the the question is dress
watch sports watch and over-the-top
weird or technically dazzling watch
um I don't have a good answer sports
watch well actually maybe you know there
is a famous Patek Philippe which is you
know a super duper hoity toity watch
company they make um what's it called
the aqua dot which is like a very kind
of weird it was the 70s you know uh it
was a it's a very
you would never if you were not a watch
Person you would not see it on someone's
wrist and think it was anything special
but it's like you know the good watch
companies are able to like just do all
the details exactly right and so it's a
very functional Fun sports watch for
dress watch
um I'm a huge fan of langa and zerna
which is this German company you know
the whole German watchmaking industry
was devastated uh not just because of
the quartz crisis but because of the
Iron Curtain and the Berlin Wall Etc but
now lasso to Germany has become second
to only Switzerland in terms of
watchmaking capabilities they've come
back to life and long engine is a German
company that makes like some of the most
beautiful dress watches in the world I
don't have a specific one that I would
want but I think that company way
outside of my price range now so yes my
future Nobel prize winning self might
splurge on that in fact I would not buy
three watches I would just buy one and
probably that would be it
for technically dazzling watches again I
don't have a particular favorite but
there are
um there are some amazing ones out there
uh people really have fun because it is
it's it's purely what can I say it's
purely frivolous I think that's the
thing to say uh there's no nothing about
I remember you know speaking of uh
religious debates when I debated William
Lane Craig
uh one of the comparisons he made was to
say that something was you know he
compared a Rolex to a Timex and you know
the Rolex being much fancier and
therefore more accurate and the Timex
being cheaper and therefore less
accurate I forget what the purpose of
the analogy was but I pointed out no
Timex is a quartz watch those are going
to be much more accurate than even the
best mechanical watches if you do a
halfway decent jobs or Rolex is a
perfectly decent mechanical watch but
it's not going to be as accurate as a as
a good cheap quartz watch so the
mechanical watches are not made for any
uh technical purpose except to kind of
have fun with it and I I kind of like
that I like the search for having fun
I'm in favor of that so anyway
um I don't remember any like the
companies or anything that do this but
there are some astronomical watches that
almost look like a little miniature
solar system on your wrist that you can
see all the planets moving around like
you have a little Aura read down there I
have no idea whether that be practical
to wear
um but again since it's not happening
I'm happy to say that would be my choice
Robert antonucci says a priority
question once again is dark energy the
only thing that affects other things
without being itself affected no back
reaction
well I can see why you would ask that
but I think that the the if you're
bothered there's an implicit thing here
that it bugs you that dark energy
affects other things without itself
being affected so I think there's two
ways to ameliorate that bothersomeness
one is in some sense it is affected
because as space time expands there's
more and more dark energy right uh
there's more there's the same amount of
dark energy per cubic centimeter there
are more cubic centimeters therefore
there's more Dark Energy so in some
sense it is definitely being affected
but the other one is the amount of dark
energy per cubic centimeter is just a
constant of nature it's like the mass of
the electron or the fine structure
constant Etc it's a parameter it's a
value so you know the fine structure
constant is not affected by things
around it but it does affect things
around it in some sense you know I think
you have to be a little bit more
um precise about what is a thing that
does affecting and so forth the you know
this is one of those questions where the
the completely technically correct but
unsatisfying answer is all the equations
work out fine if you write down the uh
theory of quantum gravity you know in
the weak energy regime with the standard
model of particle physics with some
cosmological constant with some dark
energy everything works out fine energy
conservation is obeyed in the covarian
sense that is to say in the sense of
expanding space time Etc there's nothing
weird or special about the dark energy
it's just the same kind of thing you see
elsewhere in the equations of motion of
the universe except it's a constant
rather than a variable
Dave whip says I recently heard of brown
and suskin's proposal for the second law
of quantum complexity intentionally
evocative of entropy but it continues to
grow even past thermodynamic equilibrium
if this understanding is correct would
that make it a more fundamental error of
time than entropy or is there some
characteristic of entropy is or that is
lost
um I'm not going to give you a
satisfying answer this one sorry there
isn't this idea the second law of
quantum complexity uh that Lenny suskin
to Adam Brown his collaborator and
others have talked about and but there's
two things about it number one is it's
not supposed to be a general principle
like the second law is it's supposed to
have something to do with black holes or
at least Horizons or you know Quantum
gravitational systems looked at in a
certain way
and the second thing is I'm not really
sure I haven't looked at it very closely
you know I've read the abstract but I've
not dug into the paper and tried to
reproduce the results myself
um but I'm a little skeptical of things
like this because what they do is they
Define complexity by imagining you have
a bunch of qubits okay you know
two-dimensional Quantum states that can
be zeros or ones or superpositions
thereof and you think of the universe as
a quantum computer or at least some part
of the universe as a quantum computer so
you take your qubits to finding the
state of the universe and you run them
through some gates you know and Gates
and not Gates and stuff like that just
like a regular computer except the
quantum mechanical equivalent of it and
then you can Define the complexity uh of
a state as some measure of the number of
gates you have to run it through to go
from an unentangled state to whatever
state you're looking at
I'm very
leery about the choice of gates that you
have to do that you know you can always
take any state and turn it into any
other state in one step okay but that
one step might be non-local or something
like that so I'm not quite sure where
the justification comes from for using
some gates and not others there might
very well be on page 38 of the paper a
perfectly good justification that I just
haven't seen yet so I don't think
um that I'm not completely sold on the
proposal yet but I haven't tried to be
sold on it so I'm still open-minded
about that
I'm going to group together a bunch of
questions I'm sorry they're long
questions hopefully we can keep them in
mind but you'll see they're vaguely
along the same topic so David rabinovic
says when you're in when you interviewed
Judea Pearl
he seemed to argue he saw a macroscopic
states such as billiard ball
arrangements as a fundamentally
subjective concept you have generally
leaned against this idea with a counter
that macrostates are not arbitrary but
rather are constrained by the laws of
physics but when Stephen Wolfram claimed
that broad conceptions of possible
agents leave an enormous scope for what
a macrostate might be you seem to
sympathize in part so the question is do
you have more precise views on what
constitutes the most relevant and useful
physical constraints upon observers
choosing microstates maybe you think
maybe you meant macro States I'm not
sure and how important is it to
understand these constraints to
understand entropy and emergence
then Henry Jacob says I recently
listened to the Judea Pearl interview on
causality and he asked you about time
reversibility and billiards you
mentioned core screening and statmec to
illustrate how an arrow of time emerges
Pearl felt that the way coarse graining
was done introduces a choice and is
therefore not fundamental
however you held yourself back from
responding other than saying you felt as
if the arrow was fundamental can you
elaborate here okay so I think these are
more or less the same question but
there's another question from Jim Murphy
I was listening to an to Old AMA
episodes and you had a good response to
my question about complexity and
cellular automata you explained that the
automata would need to start with some
low entropy state in order to see
complexity emerge what's interesting is
that for any particular set of rules the
states that constitute low entropy may
look very different
has anyone done research into
determining the entropy of different
states or various CA rule sets or should
I start this research fresh so okay
maybe the third question is sufficiently
different I should address the first two
first
the general idea in case you're lost by
the questions is that when we talk about
entropy it's always a macroscopic I'm
thinking classical entropy not quantum
mechanical entanglement entropy or
anything like that but classically
entropy is a macroscopic coarse-grained
idea on Boltzmann's Tombstone it says s
equals K log W what w means is the
number of microstates within a certain
macro State and a macrostate is defined
as the set of all microstates that are
observationally macroscopically the same
looking to you so in a box of gas if you
have macroscopic access to the
temperature and density and velocity of
the gas at every Point how many
different Arrangements do you have of
the microscopic atoms that have that set
of macroscopic variables that's the
macro State and from that understanding
if you start in a small entropy macro
state where there's not that many states
that look like that it's very natural
for entropy to increase and you go to
larger entropy States so once you have
defined your macro States
the fact that you have entropy for any
particular state of the universe is an
objective fact
it's conditionalized on their particular
choice of macro states that you have but
it's not something that has anything to
do with your knowledge of the system
there's a whole other way of thinking
about entropy which is more gibbsian or
shannonian in spirit where you say you
have some distribution over
possibilities and the width of the
distribution is is roughly telling you
the entropy this is not that the
boltzmanian way of doing it is how many
other ways are there counterfactually
that I could rearrange my microstates to
look the same macroscopically
so it does depend absolutely on how you
coarse grain into those macro States and
there are various people including Judea
Pearl who have sort of objected to that
saying you know who says that I should
coarse grain in that particular way but
I think that those objections are
misplaced I think that people are
imagining incorrectly that it's kind of
innocent and okay to imagine that we
have perfect information about the
system the reason why that's not okay
not only is that we don't ever have
perfect information about the system but
if we did the world would be an entirely
different seeming place there wouldn't
be an arrow of time if you had perfect
information about the system you would
just say what the system does again
we're thinking classically here you
would be laplace's demon there's no
entropy for laplace's demon so this
introduction of subjectivity in the
definition of your macro States or for
that matter if you want to be more
gibbsian information theoretic about it
in your distribution over possible
microstates these are both subjective
quantities that's absolutely necessary
that's not you know optional when you
have when you're talking about entropy
and the arrow of time the good news is
that even though it's subjective it's
not arbitrary we basically agree on what
the right way to coarse grain systems
is or at least we agree enough that the
differences don't make any difference to
how you define entropy or the fact that
it's going up so I might coarse grain by
taking a box of gas and dividing up into
one cubic millimeter cubes and then
averaging over the number of atoms and
so forth and you might divide it up into
one cubic centimeter cubes and do the
same thing so we have a different coarse
graining but they're completely
compatible with each other right
why do we all agree on how to do it
because again we Define our macro states
by what we can observe about the system
things like temperature and velocity and
pressure and density are things that we
can observe with a measuring apparatus
even if we don't actually do it we could
do it whereas the position and velocity
of every individual atom is not
something that we can observe even in
principle so I think that you know this
is something that people who
want to help themselves to perfect
microscopic information about the world
have to get over you can't do that you
don't have that information and it's
crucially important that you don't have
that information that is really where
the arrow of time comes from
so I think that answers at least as much
as I can do for the first two questions
uh for the third question maybe I
shouldn't have lumped this question in
sorry about that Jim but you know the
question is
um
has anyone done research in determining
the entropy of different states or
various cellular automata rule sets so I
think this is a different thing because
now we're talking about cellular
automata rather than statistical
mechanics and there is a huge huge
difference between the two because the
whole thing about statistical mechanics
in classical physics is the microscopic
Rules of Engagement are perfectly
reversible
that is what allows for the existence of
laplace's demon Etc who from the current
information about the world can perceive
both the future and the past the typical
cellular automata that people talk about
aren't irreversible even at the
microscopic level so you don't need to
start in a special State necessarily to
see complexity emerge it's an open
question it depends on the kind of
cellular automaton you're working about
you're working on so in the
microscopically reversible case because
information is conserved at the micro
level no new complexity can ever arise
that wasn't implicit in the state all
along whereas in the cellular automata
irreversible case you can start with
just not only low entropy but almost no
information in the initial State and it
can evolve into a very high information
density state that can't happen in
classical mechanics but it can happen in
cellular automata so it's just a very
different question I'm not giving you
the answer to the question because I'm
not quite sure what it is but it's a
very different kind of setup with
therefore different approaches are going
to be necessary
John Stout says I recently bought David
Albert's book time and chance I also
bought the probability map of the
universe essays on David Albert's time
and chance the latter makes reference to
your book from eternity to here uh yes
and in fact I think I have an essay in
that book so I hope that there's more
than just my book appearing there I
think my name appears in there
um anyway Jim John goes on the latter
makes reference to your uh sorry can you
provide some context around this issue
of the arrow of time and what the
disagreements are or alternative
theories what the alternative theories
are in terms of the arrow of time if not
driven by entropy
you know in principle one could imagine
that our current best theories of
fundamental physics are very wrong I say
that because our current best theories
of fundamental physics are fundamentally
reversible at the microscopic level as
we just talked about
macroscopically we see a world where
there's lots of irreversible things
happening uh ice cubes melting into
water breaking eggs what what have you
mixing cream into coffee and we have a
very good reconciliation of those two
facts based on the fact that we're
coarse graining and we have entropy and
the entropy started low Etc
there's a set of people and Tim Malden
might actually count himself among them
who think that actually the fundamental
laws are just not reversible that there
just is an arrow of time built in but
I'll tell you that's a very minority
point of view these days I think the
majority of physicists fall into two
camps one what you might call the
conventional picture that I just uh
sketched out where you have reversible
fundamental laws but some boundary
condition the past hypothesis that says
entropy grows and the arrow of time
stems from that
and two people who haven't thought about
it that much there's gonna be plenty of
those people uh bless their hearts but
they just haven't really worried about
this question I think that the
overwhelming number of people who have
really thought deeply about the era of
time think it comes down in one way or
another to entropy and the reason why
the alternative is not that attractive
is just because it's really putting a
huge amount of effort into pushing
against a completely open door
because the fact is there is entropy
right there is microstates we can coarse
grain we can calculate the entropy that
entropy was low whether or not you have
fundamentally reversible or irreversible
laws and that entropy will go up
so whatever you think are the
fundamental dynamics of the world we
have an arrow of time from increasing
entropy and there's a project that is
ongoing and I can you know play my
little part in it and so do other people
but connecting the growth of entropy to
other manifestations of the arrow of
time causality memory aging whatever but
I mean we already have an arrow let's
just work on understanding that Arrow
versus inventing an entirely new arrow
and then trying to give that credit for
everything that's what I think the
others are trying to do so it's not that
attractive a proposition to me
Jameson says gravity is sometimes
described as the bending of space-time
and other times described by as a force
from gravitons I've even heard that in
string theory if we were living in a
three brain that gravity is only the is
the only force that could Escape in two
extra Dimensions if it's just carried by
gravitons why is gravity still so
different than the other three forces
well there's particles in their
particles particles are different is is
one very simple answer but
um there's a sort of more subtle answer
so let me do the first answer first you
know uh gravity is special because it's
Universal and what that means is that
the particles the gravitons coupled to
everything they coupled to all of energy
and momentum in the universe
photons and gluons and w and z bosons
interact with some kinds of particles
they don't interact directly with other
kinds of particles gravitons interact
with everything that's fundamentally a
consequence of the principle of
equivalence as Einstein dawned on
Einstein back in the 1910s or whatever
so the particles interact differently is
the short answer to the question the
other answer is that you know when you
say that gravity is
due to graviton particles that's
supposed to be there's all sorts of
hidden footnotes there and caveats that
maybe you're not aware of
um it's really a field right it's really
the gravitational metric tensor field
just like photons come from the
electromagnetic field and so forth
gluons come from the chromodynamic field
and there is a regime in which the
excitations of that field look like
particles
so in particular when you're very close
to the vacuum State empty space nothing
else going on and you just perturb the
field a little bit those perturbations
look like particles but in other regimes
they don't look very particle-like at
all right inside a proton the gluon
fields do not look like individual
gluons because they're not small
perturbations of the vacuum and maybe in
a black hole near the singularity
there's really no regime in which the
gravitational field looks like a
collection of gravitons so the particle
language is a little bit less General
than the field language and the
particular way that the fields work in
general relativity of course is the very
shape of space time itself that's the
explanation in Einstein's way of
thinking about it for why gravity is
universal and couples to everything as
opposed to other forces which are Fields
living within space time rather than
Fields defining a feature of space-time
itself so the gluon feels
electromagnetic fields and so forth are
allowed to interact with some particles
and not others gravity has to interact
with everything
Frederick Apollo says why do particles
Decay into other particles is it really
just the second law
well it's not just the second law but
the second law is absolutely involved in
particle physics any interaction like
let's say you have a muon and muons can
Decay into electrons and the neutrino
anti-neutrino pair that is an allowed
interaction in particle physics the
reverse interaction is always allowed
you can always imagine taking an
electron a neutrino and an anti-neutrino
pointing them exactly at each other in
exactly the right way to make a muon at
least temporarily but as you might guess
it's harder to do that and in fact it is
just a little toy version of unmixing
the cream from the coffee or Unbreaking
the egg there's a smaller number of ways
to be a single muon then there are ways
to be an electron a neutrino and an
anti-neutrino so it's not the second law
is not the explanation for y particles
Decay into other particles period but
it's the explanation for why that's a
much more common event than several
particles coming together to make a
small number of particles
David Maxwell says my favorite modern
sci-fi is called bobiverse it tells of a
near future I.T engineer who pays to
have his brain Frozen on death but wakes
up much later as the sentience of afan
Neumann probe able to harvest Resources
with drones 3D print anything and
replicate himself he cannot travel or
communicate faster than light but he
does have Fusion engines being
artificial he's also able to live in any
speed he chooses and meet with other
Bobs in real time
etc etc
his choices are around time and
resources replicate civilize or explore
would you choose this option for life
after death and how do you think you
might prioritize your choices very
broadly would you be more an Explorer a
World Builder or a multitude
so I'm I'm once again not going to get a
very satisfying answer to this question
because I kind of question one of the
implicit assumptions of even asking the
question where you it's not implicit
it's very explicit you say would you
choose this option for life after death
so I think that I would no longer exist
there's no sense in which I can continue
my life
as a Von Neumann probe
um and this is there's a philosophical
Point here that we talked about with
Katie Elliott a little bit I think that
and we talked about with David Albert
also when I talked with him about you
know uh Captain Kirk and things like
that
strictly speaking you know why do you
think you're the same person that you
were five minutes or five years ago well
you're not exactly the same person right
you're a little bit different you've
aged a little bit you have a memory that
you didn't have back then you're even
your constituents Adam constituent atoms
are a little bit different now than they
were back then but there are reasons to
psychologically as well as physically
Identify some continuity over time
between yourself now and yourself some
time ago and we can sit down and debate
how accurate or how fundamental that
identification is but it is convenient
it serves some purpose to us because
there is continuity there
this kind of thought experiment which
I'm not arguing against this kind of
thought experiment it's a lot of fun by
all means let's let's contemplate it but
it is doing something that is enormously
far outside our experience and it's
asking us to make decisions based on our
experience which is very hard to do it
might even be fundamentally no rational
way to do it which is something we
talked about with Lori Paul back on the
podcast some time ago about
transformative experiences in other
words unlike me now and me five minutes
ago or me five years ago there's
relatively little continuity between me
now and some uploaded version of me in
some inter Stellar probe that is
completely artificial right I mean maybe
what you mean is that there are some
patterns in my neurons that you try to
replicate inside some silicon substrate
or something like that and do your best
but it's not going to be me anymore
it'll have some relationship to me but
the direct relationship that I have with
my five-year-old Sal five five years ago
self is just not there it's something
much more tenuous than that in
particular I would imagine that all of
my motivations and drives and so forth
would be completely different in that
context than they are now so I don't
think that the question would I choose
that option and how would I behave if
that option were chosen makes any sense
um you can ask a more specific question
if someone takes this and that neuronal
pathway pattern from your brain and
reproduces it in a machine and launches
it into space what you predict that
thing would do I have no idea what the
answer is but I don't think it's me in
any real sense
John Campbell says of the many ways I
could buy or borrow your books which
would you recommend I'd like to vote
with my wallet and I have my own
thoughts about the relative merits of
borrowing from the library buying a book
used buying an e-book buying a book from
the publisher Etc but I'd like to hear
yours
I appreciate the question thank you John
but you know honestly it doesn't matter
that much in terms of me making money I
think that you buying it from a
bookstore or from Amazon is probably the
best maybe buying from the publisher I
honestly don't know I haven't really
kept track I don't think it matters from
those three options
um
there's an absolutely sentimental part
of me which would like to see people buy
from bookstores from Good Old
independent bookstores or you can go to
bookshop.org and that's an internet way
of buying from independent bookstores
that's usually how I try to buy books if
I can
um but if you want to buy the ebook or
if you want to buy get it from the
library I don't make any money if you
get it from the library but I have no
objections to that whatsoever I'm a huge
fan of libraries a huge fan of people
taking my books out in libraries that's
great whatever is most convenient for
you you know I uh whatever makes you
most likely to get the book and read it
do that that would be my advice
Masterwork tools says I was explaining
the new Gravity wave results to my
father and he has a question for me that
I couldn't answer what other types of
wave are there and can we expect to be
able to eventually detect them
as I understand it we have mechanical
waves electromagnetic waves and gravity
waves am I correct on these and are
there any others we know of that we can
expect will be useful for investigating
the universe
well I think there's not quite a
parallel between some of the examples
you're giving mechanical waves
electromagnetic waves and gravity waves
those are all waves
um but mechanical waves is a huge
category I mean there are sound waves
right that's a kind of mechanical wave
but there's also vibrations there's
waves on water these are all kinds of
waves that are propagating in some
particular medium and there's
potentially huge number of different
kinds of them I think maybe what you're
thinking about are more fundamental
particle physics Notions of waves so
there are electromagnetic waves and
gravity waves right there in the basic
laws of physics unlike sound waves which
are higher level emergent kinds of
things
so if what you're asking is are there
other kinds of fundamental waves that we
might measure astrophysically the short
answer is no it does depend on whether
or not you count matter particles as
well as
uh Force carrying particles right like
in some sense because of quantum
mechanics when you detect cosmic rays or
neutrinos or high energy electrons or
whatever from space those are kind of
wavy in some sense because the quantum
mechanics but they're what we call
fermions in physics so they're actually
particle-like waves you cannot pile them
on top of each other to make bigger and
bigger waves like you can with
electromagnetic waves and gravitational
waves there are also other
forces in nature there's the weak
nuclear force and the strong nuclear
force but they're both short range
so electromagnetism and gravity are the
only two fundamental force-carrying
waves that are long range and can
therefore propagate over astrophysical
distances at least those are the only
ones we know of we have zero reason to
expect there are any others besides that
but they could be there right that's the
job of theoretical physicists to invent
models in which that's the case I've
done it myself so I think it's a
respectable thing to do but short answer
to your question in terms of wave-like
things that we might find by doing
astrophysics it's one version or another
of electromagnetism and gravity
Chris Murray says it is said that
barring proton decay Quantum tunneling
will eventually turn black dwarfs into
iron Stars than into black holes it's
been pointed out such a black hole would
come from a small fraction of the iron
star which then swallows the rest since
Quantum tunneling is overwhelmingly more
likely to form a smaller black hole
before a larger one but doesn't this
mean there would be an abundance of the
very smallest black holes first some
being on the surface whose instant
evaporation would gradually eat away the
whole star before any long-lasting black
hole could be formed
I'm not sure who is saying these things
you keep saying it is said that I'm not
sure who's saying that I'm pointing it
out this is
a tru-ish kind of scenario
um but but weirdly specific uh it's
weirdly specific because it's a thing
that can happen but other things can
happen also
um it's much more likely that Stars are
planets fall into big black holes then
that they Quantum tunnel into being
black holes in their own right but it
could happen
um but what when it happens if you so
you're correct I think that when there's
a Quantum tunneling event that makes a
new black hole that black hole is going
to be very small
but it will eat right it will accrete
other things or it will just evaporate
away right away it's very possible to
evaporates away right away in which case
it's just not there anymore
um but if it's big enough that it can
survive by growing by eating then it
will generally eat up whatever star or
Planet it's in long long before that
star war planet has a chance to Quantum
tunnel into another black hole so
there's no regime that I know about
where you will accumulate many small
Quantum tunnel black holes before the
whole thing just collapses to one big
black hole
Gregory kuznick says if you were
education Emperor how would you reform
College admissions policies
yeah I'm not going to be education
Emperor anytime soon I'm not quite sure
who counts as that uh it's not something
that I've put a tremendous amount of
thought into very honestly I do have
like vague feelings about it I think
that
we stress it too much College admissions
you know I think that the undergraduate
college experience is just not nearly as
affected well sorry I should say this
the educational side of the
undergraduate college experience is not
nearly as affected by where you go as
parents and high school students tend to
think it is I was a grad student at
Harvard I know plenty of undergraduates
who did not get a great education while
they were there at Harvard because they
chose to focus on doing other things I
was an undergraduate at Villanova and I
know that there were students there who
got a wonderful education as long as
you're at a relatively good school and
you put in the effort as the student you
can absolutely get a wonderful education
almost anywhere there are slight
differences that can be very important
for example
I definitely suffered as a Villanova
undergraduate from not having a graduate
program in physics that I could sort of
sneak into most undergraduates who
wanted to grow up to go to grad school
if they're at a place that already has a
graduate program then they will take
some classes ahead of time it helps
preparation and things like that but
that's a very specific thing if you want
to eventually go to grad school it helps
you to go to an undergraduate school
that has a grad school there it's not
necessary if you're at a smaller school
you can get more attention so you know
there's pluses and minuses but the idea
that you know you have to go to the top
school to get a good education I think
is entirely wrong in fact it's very
often the case that the top schools are
the ones where well again this is not
necessarily a correlation but there's
plenty of professors at top schools who
are not really interested in
undergraduate education what makes the
top schools the top schools is their
research right their scholarship their
intellectual output it makes a big
difference for graduate school where you
go because there you're working with an
advisor and that advisor really has a
huge effect on your life
for undergraduate education it's
honestly probably the biggest effect is
who your peers are who your other
students are going there and the benefit
of going to a place like Harvard or
Princeton or Stanford is that you're
hanging out with people who are going to
go on to rule the world and that can be
beneficial to you so I don't know how to
uh reform it but I would lower the
temperature on discussions about it you
know honestly I could see an argument
for just making it random you know
having some lower cut off like if you're
okay you're good enough to get into the
basic schools and then we'll just
randomize who gets in what I think that
would be fine you know in many ways
not necessarily advocating that but I
might not be worse than the current
system let's put it that way there is of
course a lot of discussion about this
issue right now because of affirmative
action and the Supreme Court coming down
against it which is just I think the the
reaction against affirmative action is
just weird and bad I think and it's also
intellectually misplaced you know
affirmative action is not a great system
for those of you who are not in the U.S
affirmative action is a system
According to which uh black people and
other underrepresented minorities get
preferential treatment when being
accepted into colleges or other things
you know you could Define the term
affirmative action differently it's not
a great system because you know you
would like in principle to very
carefully judge each individual case and
if someone really was discriminated
against personally then okay you can
make up for that in your admissions
decisions because they're fighting
against this extra Optical
Etc et cetera but all that takes effort
and time and resources that places don't
have the thing about affirmative action
is it's cheap and easy just say okay
we're going to let in more members from
this particular applicant pool to
increase the diversity of the school
that's it right it's just not a big deal
it's it's cheap and easy and yet super
effective Studies have shown that
affirmative action has absolutely
changed the demographics of the United
States by contributing greatly to the
growth of a black middle class because
people go to these schools they wouldn't
otherwise have gotten into they get to
know friends and whatever they're
exposed to a whole different world and
that helps them later in life so I think
that you know there's various things to
be said I don't think that schools
should discriminate against Asian
Americans like they sometimes do because
otherwise Asian Americans
disproportionately do very well on tests
and would get into schools
on the other hand I don't think that you
know test scores should be the
overwhelming thing either I think it is
perfectly okay to take plenty of
different considerations uh under your
advisement when you're letting people
into schools so overall I don't care
that much but I'm absolutely in favor of
doing things to make a diverse and
interesting student body
Peter Kane says are there any fun and
interesting ideas about dark matter that
could be used for science fiction novels
TV shows or films you know it's very
hard because one of the things we know
about dark matter is it doesn't interact
with itself very strongly if it did then
it would be more like ordinary matter
and the distribution of Dark Matter
would be very similar to that of
ordinary matter but that's not true Dark
Matter halos in a galaxy or cluster tend
to be big and puffy and diffuse whereas
the ordinary matter because it uh
interacts electromagnetically you can
give off photons lose energy dissipate
and fall to the center of halos as we
discussed in the solo episode recently
so the zeroth approximation your first
guess is that dark matter just doesn't
interact with anything else at least not
very much and therefore not very
interesting for science fiction novels
Etc
um maybe you can try to be more creative
you know I did write a paper with Lottie
Ackerman Matt Buckley Mark kaminkowski
about dark radiation we imagine that
there could be a version of
electromagnetism that only interacted
with dark matter and once that's true
and we show that it is allowed at least
it seems to be allowed so you can then
imagine
dark atoms dark chemistry dark molecules
Etc but it has to be different than
ordinary matter because of just what I
said because the Dynamics of dark matter
are different so I'm not sure if there's
a regime where you can do interesting
things like that uh but that even that
would still be you know the Dynamics of
things going on in the dark matter by
itself not interacting with ordinary
matter if Dark Matter interacted
noticeably with ordinary matter we would
have detected it a long time ago so in
terms of like being useful to we people
made of ordinary matter I don't really
see how dark matter can be very helpful
Simon Carter says I was beginning to be
convinced by Tim Malden's argument for
pilot waves but in the reflections you
mentioned that making it compatible with
Quantum field theory is a hurdle too far
could you expand on that please
um I can't expand very much for the
reasons that I've said earlier that I
have not actually dug into the details
about these alternatives to everreadyian
quantum mechanics but there's a
difference in philosophy here okay in
bohmian mechanics pilot wave theories
they were first developed in the context
of
non-relativistic quantum mechanics of
Point particles and the motto was you
know why do you see wave-like Behavior
sometime and particle-like behavior
sometimes in quantum mechanics in Pilot
wave theories the answer is because
there are both waves and particles right
and that seems good but then you realize
well actually in modern physics The
World Isn't made of particles the
particles are just quantized excitations
of fields so now what do you do and and
the bomian people don't agree yet on
what to do there are different
strategies going on the point is that
one way or another you need Quantum wave
functions and something else and some
hidden variables so constructing a
quantum theory in bohmi mechanics is
more difficult than doing so and never
any quantum mechanics because it's more
complicated there are more ingredients
and more equations so there are choices
you need to make things you need to
think about and Quantum field Theory
doesn't Naturally Fit in maybe you can
squeeze it in some way whereas with
Everett you just tell me what the
hamiltonian is which runs the Dynamics
and you're done that's all you got to do
everything else is supposed to follow
from that underlying equation and the
same thing goes true but even more when
you get to something like quantum
gravity where you're not going to assume
ahead of time there is anything called
the metric tensor it might be emergent
and so forth so again for Everett this
is all Plug and Play it's all very easy
every time you invent a new kind of
quantum theory you have to reinvent your
pilot wave theory but you don't have to
do that in many worlds one of the
reasons why it's so much more attractive
says I read Thomas hertog's book thanks
thanks to your recent podcast Thomas
admits in the book that Stephen
Hawking's favorite technique of rotating
time into an imaginary direction to
create euclidean quantum gravity has
long been dismissed as a Cambridge
eccentricity there's a difference
between mathematical calculational tools
like Wick rotation and Steven's belief
that imaginary times in some sense
physically real how do other
professionals view euclidean quantum
gravity as nothing more than a dubious
parlor trick
well it's an interesting question so for
those of you who don't know the
background here when you learn
relativity when you learn special
relativity first and then general
relativity you learn that basically the
idea that space time is a unified thing
means that you can calculate distances
or intervals in space time just like you
can in regular space in regular space if
you have XYZ coordinates you use
Pythagoras's Theorem to do that x
squared plus y squared plus Z squared
equals the distance squared okay the
difference is in space time that you do
the same thing with not only space but
also time so it's t x y z the difference
is that there's a minus sign in front of
the new version of Pythagoras's theorem
for the time Direction this is all
explained in Grizzly detail in the
biggest ideas in the universe volume 1
space time in motion so it's minus t
squared plus x squared plus y squared
plus Z squared and that's you know fine
it fits the data and you can test it Etc
but it's a little bit mathematically
inconvenient so what you can do is if
you want a little bit more mathematical
convenience make a change of variables
from T the time coordinate to Tau where
the relationship is T equals I times Tau
okay so I square root of minus one we're
just defining a variable nothing no one
can stop you from doing that but in
terms of Tau which is minus I times T if
you want to put it that way
minus t squared is plus Tau squared
right so in terms of the Tau coordinate
the metric the distance is plus Tau
squared plus x squared plus y squared
plus Z squared that's a euclidean kind
of metric which is why we call it
euclidean space or when we do gravity
euclidean quantum gravity now this trick
turns out to be super useful in ordinary
Quantum field Theory it's just a trick
in Quantum field Theory that's the way
that we usually think about it Wick
rotation is the is sometimes the word
word that is used to describe it because
we're thinking of time as being a
complex number t plus I Tau and rotating
from the t-axis to the I Axis is rotate
to the Tau axis is rotating from a real
number to an imaginary number so we also
call it imaginary time
and it doesn't make that much of a
conceptual difference in Quantum field
Theory it makes a big conceptual
difference in gravity because you're
integrating over the space of all
possible metrics and now these metrics
are euclidean metrics rather than
space-time metrics so you guess or posit
that the answer is the same that it
doesn't matter whether you integrate
over euclidean metrics or lorenzian
metrics as we say space-time metrics
nobody really knows for sure but it's
certainly easier to deal with the
euclidean calculation so you cross your
fingers and you hope it works
that is kind of F of
the particular program that Hawking and
others have called euclidean quantum
gravity half of it is this rotation from
real time to imaginary time but the
other half is in the context of quantum
cosmology
dramatically cutting down on the number
of degrees of freedom that you're
considering by just assuming that the
universe is homogeneous and isotropic to
start right so-called mini super space
models and maybe then you perturb it a
little bit by by adding some
perturbations on top of that but you're
still treating the metric as the
fundamental thing and it's it's not very
holographic or emergent or anything like
that
so I think that you know people respect
this tool very very much as a tool for
doing calculations the heartlehocking
vacuum state in the quantum field Theory
version of this really just is the
vacuum state right you just calculated a
vacuum state which is an interesting
useful thing to do so I think that most
people think that it has some use I
think that most people think that it's
not going to be the definitive final way
to construct a full theory of quantum
gravity
Paul Hess says if you could meet a
well-versed philosopher from 100 years
in our future what would you ask them
about and do you think their answer
would be any more valuable than asking a
well-versed contemporary philosopher I
am trying to get at whether you feel the
philosophy is an area that actually
advances like physics does
well I absolutely think the philosophy
advances whether advances like physics
does is a harder question because it's a
very different field physics is about
creating models and fitting them to the
data right and philosophy is not about
that partly sometimes that happens at
the boundaries of course between physics
and philosophy but philosophy is about
the conceptual logical analysis of the
underlying arguments not about creating
models and fitting them to the data so
it's a different kind of advancement
obviously in my mind philosophy advances
you know if you've ever heard me say
thinking about morality for example well
you can consider consequentialist
theories or deontological theories or
virtue ethics theories right so there's
a kind of a road map for different
possibilities as soon as you say those
words you are borrowing advances that
were made by previous philosophers even
if the advance is not of the form here's
the once and for all Final Answer
understanding the space of possibilities
is absolutely an advance some areas of
philosophy are more rigorous and logical
and you prove theorems in mathematical
Logic for example right uh there's no
question that you know once you've
proven some theorems you've made a
little bit of an advance what I would
want to ask a future philosopher there's
lots of questions I would like to ask I
would like to ask you know what they're
thinking these days about morality and
ethics meta ethics and the grounding for
ethics the role of Consciousness and Ai
and emergence and things like that
there's a whole bunch of things I would
like to ask not even to mention what I
do for a living the philosophy of
cosmology and and quantum mechanics and
the arrow time all there's a whole bunch
of things I'd be very interested to see
what philosophers have learned over the
course of a century
Ned Grady says in your most recent solo
podcast I heard gravity is non-local
along with some quick examples of the
non-locality EG black hole information
that's the first I've heard of it after
listening to plenty of your podcast can
you explain in any more detail the
examples and their consequences
well this is not something that is very
well understood let's be very clear and
it's a purely quantum gravity statement
that gravity is done local classically
gravity is perfectly local it's a local
field Theory and what that means is you
have an equation of motion Einstein's
equation that holds separately at every
point in space time okay that's what it
means it what happens at one point in
space time is being affected by its
derivatives or its very very nearest
neighbors not affected directly or
immediately by things that are happening
far away in quantum mechanics there's my
personal point of view here and there
are things that are well recognized by
others in my personal point of view uh
locality is something that we need to
explain why it's a good approximation at
all because quantum mechanics doesn't
look local it doesn't have space built
into it much less locality you have to
get that as an emerging thing so to me
it's completely unsurprising that there
might be some non-locality the question
is what exactly is
the kind of non-locality that arises the
evidence that we have that this is an
important thing comes like you say from
black hole information but also just
from the holographic principle right if
you think about adsc FD the claim is
that there are two theories that are
equivalent to each other one is defined
on the boundary it's a theory without
gravity and one is defined in the bulk
it's a theory with gravity in one Higher
Dimension so the relationship between
those theories is gonna have to be
non-local they're not even the same
number of spatial Dimensions right so
holography if you believe that it's a
good approximation or valid in any case
at all is going to be a very Vivid
example of non-locality in quantum
gravity the black hole information
puzzle is also seemingly such an example
because the whole reason it's a puzzle
is because once you send the information
to the black hole it's behind a horizon
and it's hard to see how it gets out
how does it get out well through
something non-local but very very subtle
okay we don't know the details about
that I don't know the details or people
who are working on it and and have made
a lot of progress I don't think the
situation is quite settled yet but
there's evidence that you know the
quantum mechanical level there's little
tiny influences that share entanglement
over non-local distances but it's not
something that is perfectly well
understood right now
Brian says I find your work in
discussions of position and momentum as
emergent properties from the state
Vector in Hilbert's base fascinating do
you have similar lines of thinking about
the emergence of fields and the internal
spaces they inhabit
well not really I mean I have some
aspirations some vague ideas some
scribbles maybe some notes in a notebook
somewhere I have not put a lot of effort
into thinking about that uh in part
because it's supposed to be easier you
know getting fields or whatever to
emerge from quantum mechanics already
shouldn't be that hard but then it
becomes hard when you want to get the
right Fields right the fields that we
actually have in the standard model of
particle physics Etc and also when you
want that to play nicely with the idea
of space and maybe space time themselves
emerging so there are people who thought
about that but I haven't put a lot of
effort into it myself quite yet
Christopher humble says my question
concerns Cormac McCarthy did your past
ever cross at the Santa Fe Institute and
if so what were those conversations like
also more generally can you talk about
the interdisciplinary collaboration of
The Institute and the kinds of
conversations that go on
you know I I almost didn't answer this
question because the answer is no I
never ran across cormick McCarthy uh the
time that I started spending more time
at the Santa Fe Institute was about the
time he had started spending less time
just because he was not feeling as well
um but when I was just there most
recently
um there was a little Memorial uh
celebration for Cormac McCarthy he was
and so I was there for that and it did
make an impression he was a very big
Presence at The Institute you know he uh
had a lot to do with the physical design
of the place you know he had opinions he
helped redo the entire Library he
donated wood for the stairs you know
from his farm and things like that uh I
was what was claimed and I have no
reason to doubt it is that he never
really liked Santa Fe you know he was
not a new Mexican he was a Texan
originally and the reason why he moved
to Santa Fe was to be close to the Santa
Fe Institute and to interact with people
there uh if people don't know his two
most recent novels his last two novels
the passenger and Stella Maris are very
much based on conversations that Cormac
McCarthy had with physicists especially
at the Santa Fe Institute
um he helped SFI rewrite their you know
publicity materials things like that he
would help people edit their books um
you know in some you get a you get a
feeling that he had a certain uh
grumpiness about him in some cases but
also a really
um touching warmth about him in other
cases so uh I'm sorry that I didn't get
to interact with him much more in terms
of the interdisciplinary collaborations
and conversations that go on you know a
lot of the effort
or a lot of the secret to success at a
place like SFI is just making sure the
people you invite are into the spirit of
the place right away so you know the
thing about SFI is you go to lunch and
everyone goes to lunch it's served and
everyone sits in the same place and you
can sit down next to whoever you want
and there might be an architect and a
historian and a linguist and a computer
scientist but the thing is they're not
randomly chosen Architects and
historians Etc they are ones who want to
come to the Santa Fe Institute they are
the ones who are interested in talking
to physicists and to biologists and to
whoever right and so that's what makes
it great and there's plenty of people
out there who are interested in this
kind of interdisciplinary collaboration
as a matter of finding them and getting
them into the right place you know not
every physicist wants to talk to a
historian or an economist or Etc but SFI
attracts those people
nolita s says I really enjoyed listening
to your episode with Katie Elliott would
you kindly expand on the connection you
postulated in newcomb's Paradox between
eternalism and the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
I'm gonna have to apologize for not
remembering exactly what I said uh I I
was thinking about in the case of
nukem's paradox you know if you believe
in quantum mechanics then the existence
of this kind of spooky being who knows
exactly what the future is going to hold
is much harder to understand in quantum
mechanics where there's Randomness in
the world right so if you think that
there's some Quantum fluctuations that
will prevent you from getting the right
reward then is harder to even set up
nukem's Paradox I don't think that many
worlds either implies eternalism or is
against it or anything like that I do
think that there's an overall philosophy
of physics that says you know the
physical laws describe what happens in
reality as convenient summaries of the
actual motion dynamics of the physical
world and the physical world comes first
first and the World includes various
moments of time and described by
different states of the wave function so
it it all kind of fits together into a
neat package that includes many worlds
and eternalism but I wouldn't want to
say that either one of them nudges you
in the direction of the other you can be
classical eternalist perfectly well or a
bow mean eternalist or whatever
all right I'm going to group two
questions together doorbell Jeff says
I'm a PhD student in observational
cosmology and I don't get the
cosmological constant problem to my
limited understanding of quantum field
Theory at a certain energy scale we
measure the renormalized value of a
parameter of the theory and thanks to
renormalization we can then predict how
it scales with energy that is correct
cosmologists measure the renormalized
value of the cosmological constant to be
small and this is often claimed to be a
mystery but we can obtain that value
through a renormalization procedure to
me this seems to solve the problem like
it solves the problem for any other
parameter we measure in physics what am
I missing
whereas Bill Quirk says I enjoyed
episode 245 crisis in physics you
mentioned the difficulty of
understanding the small but non-zero
number for the cosmological constant
what are some of the ways that people
have tried to explain why the number is
so small but not zero I believe the
calculation depends on the plank scale
what would the plank scale have to be
for the number to be as small as The
observed cosmological constant
so it is completely true that the
cosmological constant at the end of the
day is something you go out and measure
and you can always
fit that into your theory as a
renormalized parameter that you measure
just like you can fit the mass of the
Higgs boson or the fine structure
constant or whatever
that's not the mystery there's no
mathematical obstacle to just dealing
with whatever cosmological constant you
measure the mystery is that the value of
it seems unnatural to us this whole
procedure of renormalization is not just
a way to fit The Final Answer into your
calculations but it also offers a
natural scale for these answers to be
act especially when you have numbers
that are dimensionful or you know they
are compared to other numbers in some
way and there's a set of contributions
that you add up I think that the real
impact of the cosmological constant
problem comes from imagining that you
treat it as the sum of many different
contributions right so there's a vacuum
energy in a different Quantum field but
there's a separate contribution to the
vacuum energy from the electromagnetic
field and from the neutrino fields and
from the Quark fields and all these
different fields right some of these
contributions are positive some of them
are negative there could even just be a
classical bear contribution right and
the Mystery is why in the world do all
these positive and negative numbers add
up to give you such a tiny number
that's the mystery and you know you it
is very important to emphasize that it
is clearly a misunderstanding right so
you can't be too adamant about what I
just said adding up all these
contributions and getting the tiny
number as the right thing to do it seems
to be the right thing to do from our
current understanding of effective
Quantum field Theory but it doesn't give
you the right answer so clearly
something's wrong that's easy the hard
part is what is wrong so to Bill's
question I don't have any good theories
to explain why the cosmoshal constant is
small
um I proposed a couple but they're not
great
I wouldn't say that they're on the right
track I will I will mention two ideas
that are out there that may or may not
develop into the right answer the best
idea we have right now is the anthropic
principle right there's a there are
small numbers in physics and the
cosmological constant is has the special
full property that it is small but if it
were bigger we wouldn't be here to talk
about it okay it would not allow for the
existence of galaxies and stars Etc so
therefore if you have a Multiverse with
different values of the cosmological
constant you can account for its
smallness by saying that we only see
those regions in which the value is
small this was argued by lindae and
Weinberg and others all the way back in
the 80s maybe even before that who knows
so that's absolutely a possibility it
would be a sad possibility in the sense
that it would remove the ability to
create a clever theory that actually
predicted the value of the cosmological
constant the other perspective which Tom
Banks and others have pushed for a while
and I'm actually quite fond of is
in the case of the cosmological constant
the entire Paradigm of effective field
theory is just not the right way to
think about it
he has a paper Tom has a paper the
cosmological constant maybe with Willie
Fishler the cosmological constant as a
boundary condition and the idea is the
following that if you live in decider
space which is the empty space solution
to general relativity with a positive
cosmotual constant then you have a
horizon around us in all directions it's
sort of like we're in the center of the
Horizon rather than outside the Horizon
as we would be in the case of a black
hole
and there's an entropy associated with
that Horizon and it's the area of the
Horizon in blank units just like the
entropy of a black hole calculated by
Hawking way back when and you can make
the case that it's a high entropy state
so the dimensionality of Hilbert's space
is e to that entropy so e to the 10 to
the 122 roughly speaking okay so it's a
very big number the dimensionality of
Hilbert space but the point is what Tom
would say and what I would completely
agree with is if that's the right way to
think about it that's not something you
get by renormalizing of parameter in
your effective field Theory that's the
dimensionality of Hilbert space that's
just a fixed number that's just given to
you by God okay it's not the sum of
various contributions and then so this
doesn't solve the cosmological constant
problem it just says you're thinking
about it in the wrong way the
cosmotional consonant is not supposed to
be thought of under the rubric of
effective field Theory okay it doesn't
tell you why it's so small but tells you
that it's not the kind of thing you
should think of as being the sum of many
different contributions some positive
and some negative
Thomas prunty says I've heard you
describe Gage theories a couple times
like in the crisis in physics episode
and while I think I understand the words
I'm still missing something if all field
configurations related by a gauge
transformation are physically the same
then how can that transformation also
generate a force which does not have
real effects it seems like the Symmetry
should keep things the same rather than
generate something new
yeah so I think that there's an
ingredient missing here which is that
the gauge transformation itself does not
generate a force what happens is you
would like your theory to be invariant
under gauge Transformations and that
means you have to be able to compare
what is going on at different locations
in space how have you rotated your axes
in some charge space or color space or
whatever at one point compared to
another one what that means is you crank
through the math and figure that out
means that you have to introduce another
field a field in addition to the
electron or the quark and whatever you
had there has to be another field that
helps you compare what is going on at
one point in space to what's going on at
another point in space that field is
called the connection field or the gauge
potential and how that field changes
from place to place the field is
constant if the connection is just
constant everywhere then there is no
Force then there's no thing that is
physically pulling particles together or
pushing them apart but that field
contains energy the connection field if
it has twists and turns in it those cost
energy to make and we call those twists
and turns the electric field and the
magnetic field and so the force carrying
fields are related to the changes
through space time of the connection
field that helps you implement those
gauge Transformations so it's not that
the gauge symmetry itself gives rise to
a force but mathematically making it all
work out introduces another field which
gives rise to the force
Sandro Stuckey says I love the episode
with Katie Elliott during your
discussion of the principles fission
reason I picked up on this statement of
yours which resonated with me how
confident are we that when we're
reasoning about things that are very
different from our universe that we can
say things that are not overly tainted
by our Real World experience I feel like
that's a big issue that goes right down
to the foundations of philosophy and
logic itself but maybe that's not what
you meant can you elaborate a bit on
that thought and share some more of your
ideas on the topic
well I don't think I can give a once and
for all definitive answer to it but I do
agree with you I think that this is a
central concern when you're doing
philosophy or for that matter when
you're doing science
we have certain intuitions feelings
about how the world works we are not
blank slates we human beings right so
when we do the practice of science which
is to propose theoretical models that
might explain the world and then
experimentally test them against what
the world is actually doing
we naturally tend to gravitate to things
that make sense to us that make
intuitive sense to us sometimes the data
or some other feature of the world is
just so unmistakable so impossible to
miss that it pushes us away from our
intuitions like in relativity and
quantum mechanics and so forth even in
natural selection in some ways but other
times it doesn't or other times its
influence is a little bit weaker so we
have to work harder and there's no magic
pill there's no algorithm that says here
is how to avoid being tainted by your
everyday experience of the single
universe that you find yourself in you
have to work at it so it's just a matter
of you know practice and concentration
to be able to take a step back and say
like okay am I trying to force the
universe into my uh preferences or am I
taking the Universe on its own terms
Dirk schmidthoffer says what is your
sleep schedule roughly hours per day do
you take naps or are you one of those
people who only need three hours a night
I am not one of those people who only
three take need uh three hours a night I
would love to get eight hours a night
probably it's more like six usually
um big fan of naps when I can get them I
can't always get them especially after a
big meal or something like that but you
know the sleep schedule changes around
depending on what I'm doing how I'm
traveling things like that I'm just not
a very organized person when it comes
right down to it I don't know whether
that's
useful information or not
Dan inch says do you have any plans to
incorporate the cats into your
Reflections videos the spectacle of cats
crawling over a famous physicist would
be fun even if they are not in a
superposition you know I would love it
if the cats wanted to participate Ariel
and caliban but I think that they don't
you know I've noticed they don't like it
when I'm sitting alone in my office
talking into the microphone they think
that's weird I know other cats are
different you know every cat is
different they have their own
personalities that's part of the charm
so they're very happy to climb over me
if I'm just sitting and reading but if
I'm talking into the computer they are
not interested in that they will go
search for other fun maybe just because
they can tell that I'm concentrating on
something else they're they're not as
interested in bugging me they're like
most cats if you have a book oh they
love that they love sitting on the book
but if I'm at the computer they're less
interested
okay I'm gonna group two questions
together Aaron Munger says shouldn't
boltzmann brains become less likely over
enormous amounts of time as particles
become more spread out in space and
interact less often and then you mizyara
says how can a boltzmann brain pop up in
the very very distant future if in this
very distant future there will be
nothing to interact with the quantum
fields and produce particles well this
is actually a contentious issue okay let
me tell you the conventional wisdom and
then I'll tell you a little spin on it
the conventional wisdom is that as we
just said a little bit ago if you have a
positive cosmological constant and you
approach a desitter phase of the
universe then you have a horizon around
you that Horizon has an entropy and as
Hawking showed for black holes a long
time ago having a horizon with an
entropy also implies a temperature
so this is a feature of quantum field
Theory and curved space time that in the
future even though everything empties
out classically Quantum mechanically
there is still a non-zero temperature
and so naively you expect that at that
temperature and the temperature does not
go to zero okay it goes to a certain
number that depends on the value of the
cosmological constant the higher the
temperature
so it does not asymptote to zero it
asymptotes to some finite non-zero
number it's a very very low number but
you know much lower than the microwave
background temperature today but still
not zero so the conventional way of
thinking is that if you have a non-zero
temperature you have thermal
fluctuations they're very very rare very
very mild but you have infinitely long
to wait So eventually you will get some
dramatic large fluctuations
I think that that's a mistake I think a
conventional wisdom is wrong about that
at least if it let's put it this way
it's not necessary it depends on details
of quantum gravity and things like that
in fact it depends on the dimensionality
of Hilbert space and whether we can
consider our observable universe as a
closed system or open system Etc so I
wrote a paper with Kim body and Jason
pollock a while ago making this point
that the word temperature means
something a little bit different in
quantum mechanics and classical
mechanics in classical mechanics the
temperature of a box of gas or something
like that is the average kinetic energy
of all the molecules up to some constant
factor in quantum mechanics it's a
little bit different because it in the
classical box of gas even if the macro
state is constant right even if you're
in equilibrium so all of your gas is
perfectly smooth everywhere the
microstate is not constant at a constant
temperature at a fixed time aperture the
molecules are moving around so the fact
that the state looks like it's static is
just a trick because you're not seeing
the microstate you're only seeing the
macro State whereas in quantum mechanics
a state that is in thermal equilibrium
what we call a thermal state in quantum
mechanics is actually truly static
microscopically as well as
macroscopically so there are no thermal
fluctuations that dynamically bring
things into existence like they would in
a moving around box of gas okay this is
a subtle difference but an obvious one
once you think about it
between what we mean by a thermal state
in quantum mechanics and the thermal
state in classical mechanics in quantum
mechanics there's no actual single
unique micro state where the particles
are moving there is a unique Quantum uh
density Matrix or or yeah it's a density
Matrix if you have a thermal state but
it's static because nothing is happening
so Kim and Jason and I argue that in
fact if that's the kind of state that
the Universe asymptotes to in the future
which it arguably is then you will not
get fluctuations into boltzmann brains
so I would say and not everyone agrees
with us even though they should so I
would say that the question about
whether or not bullsman brains actually
do fluctuate into existence in the real
world is an open one we don't know
whether or not that's actually going to
be what happens not to mention we don't
know whether the cosmological constant
will last forever and things like that
those are separate questions
Mark says would your views on religion
and Atheism be substantively different
had you not studied and been trained in
astronomy and astrophysics and were
instead a non-science professional or
Tradesman
well you know as we just discussed a
little bit ago I would not be me if I
were not uh someone who studied what I
studied I'd be a different person so
you're not asking what I would think
you're asking what some completely
different person would think and you
know that's impossible to tell if what
you mean is do you do I think that my
studies in astronomy and astrophysics
had a large impact on my opinions about
Theology and religion not a large impact
no I mean I think vaguely maybe thinking
like a scientist has had a large impact
but I don't know whether if I were a
completely different profession so I
mean this is why it's a difficult
hypothetical question I don't know why I
would be a different kind of profession
whether I would still have the love of
Science and the interest in science that
I have there's plenty of people out
there of course who are not in any way
experts are knowledgeable about science
who are still atheists so I'm not quite
sure if there's going to be a strong
connection there
o or OA says it's been stated several
times in the podcast and elsewhere that
an event horizon is not a thing and you
wouldn't notice passing through it if
the title forces are sufficiently small
but once inside the black hole all
future paths must be closer to the
singularity what does that mean for
biological functions like pumping blood
or sending signals over nerves
yeah there's two things going on here
um one is the Event Horizon which is a
location in space time and again you're
right it's not a thing uh and I
therefore say if when I'm careful I say
if the black hole is big enough you
would not notice when you cross the
Event Horizon so what is the size of the
black hole have to do with anything and
the answer is that there are tidal
gravitational effects title as in
t-i-d-a-l okay in other words when
you're near a black hole depending on
its size again and the smaller the more
dramatic the title effects are gravity
is pulling you in some directions and
pushing you in others just like the
tides here on Earth are pulled toward
the moon but they are also squeezed in
the direction perpendicular to the line
of sight pointing toward the moon that's
what tides are so gravity doesn't just
pull overall it also stretches
differentially in different directions
that's a very noticeable effect and as
small all black hole where the
differences from place to place are
large the noticeability is bigger this
is what leads to the phenomenon known as
spaghettification if you fall into a
black hole eventually you're going to be
stretched in One Direction and squeezed
in other directions and turned into a
little piece of spaghetti so you will
very definitely notice the gravitational
field of the black hole it's just that
there's no signpost precisely at the
location of what we call the Event
Horizon
Redmond says with the unambiguous
detection of polarized b-mode swirls in
the cosmic microwave background
constitute case-closed evidence of
cosmic inflation
so for those of you who don't know uh
when you have inflation inflation in the
early Universe there's still Quantum
fluctuations in the early universe so
inflation tries to make the universe as
smooth as possible but it can't make it
perfectly smooth because of these
Quantum fluctuations Quantum
uncertainties if you like and that's
what if inflation is Right gives rise to
the density perturbations we see in the
cosmic microwave background
that's a very nice picture in inflation
and it's one of the reasons why people
are so positive about the idea of
inflation but it's not you know knock
down evidence for inflation because
maybe there's some other mechanism that
we haven't invented yet that accounts
for those fluctuations so people who
think about inflation have pointed out
that there is another thing that
inflation does it doesn't just lead to
fluctuations in densities it leads to
fluctuations in the gravitational field
as well which show up as gravitational
waves and those have a very specific
unique signature in the cosmic microwave
background a certain kind of
polarization signature that is called
the B mode as opposed to the E mode the
E and B are the signals for electric
field and magnetic field but they don't
mean that in this case they just mean
different mathematical characterizations
of the polarization pattern in the CMB
and the E mode is predicted to be their
whether or not there are gravitational
waves and it has already been observed
the B mode is predicted to be a special
thing predicted by inflation and it has
not been observed yet to be a little bit
more careful about that
a primordial B mode has not been
observed a b mode from the very early
Universe there are other things that can
give rise to be modes in the later
universe that don't give us an evidence
for inflation or against it so the
question is this is a prediction of
inflation would it be Case Closed
evidence no because there is never Case
Closed evidence in science that's just
not how things work especially when the
science is something as speculative and
hard to constrain as the super duper
early Universe the question again would
be is there something else that could
possibly give rise to the same signature
is there another model or another theory
and and we don't know of one right now
but what you would do is just you would
be a good Bayesian you would say what is
the chance that I would see the
signature if inflation were right versus
if it were not right and I would update
my credences appropriately I would say
that it would be strong evidence a lot
of people's minds would be noticeably
shifted by observing B modes but it's
not Case Closed evidence in any real
sense
Emil Rojas says are particles in an atom
or molecule Quantum entangled or in the
nucleus for that matter
you know yes they are but it's a subtle
kind of thing and I'm gonna try to say
things that are all completely true
let's see if I can succeed here uh the
reason why they are is because the kind
of particles let's say electrons let's
stick to a specific example electrons in
an atom okay electrons in an atom are
identical particles
there's no difference between one
electron and another one you can't say
well I'm I noticed electron a over here
and electron B over there other than to
say where you found them so if you have
let's say two electrons that are in two
different orbitals in an atom in the
same it doesn't matter the same atom
could be a different atom very far away
whatever two different electrons right
and you measure one of them you can't
say which one you've measured there's no
such thing and that is a feature of them
being entangled with each other the
reason why I have to be very cautious
about this is because it doesn't quite
have the same implications that you're
used to entanglement having when I talk
about entanglement when you talk about
like spins being up and down and Alice
and Bob and an epr experiment then
there's a feature that says you know if
if you know the particles are entangled
so their spins are oppositely aligned
then we say when you measure one and
it's spin up you instantly know the
other one is spin down so you've learned
something about the particle over there
in the case of electrons entangled in an
atom I mean maybe their spins are also
entangled in such a way but we're
ignoring that for right now we're just
talking about the necessary entanglement
because they are identical particles
you don't learn anything about the other
electron by measuring one all you do is
that you learn that the other one is the
other place so if you have two different
orbitals and you know exactly what they
are and you have exactly two electrons
in them they are in some entangled wave
function but all you learn by measuring
one is that the other one is in the
other one okay so you don't actually get
any new information by measuring them
but strictly speaking they are entangled
yes but because of this observational
implication you can very well treat them
as if they are not so when you take your
chemistry class you don't need to learn
about entanglement or anything because
there's two electrons in two different
orbitals but they're identical it
doesn't matter which one is in which one
so if you just want to talk about the
electron that is in this orbital and the
electron that is in that orbital you're
fine all the physics is the same all the
observational consequences are the same
Etc
Danny avidan asks a priority question
last time I asked you who constitutes a
moral subject that is how should we
treat morality a follow-up please do you
think we can understand analyze critique
argue and expand our moral system
without a definition of who is and who
should be included in it
no I think that you know obviously if
you're going to talk about morality you
better talk about who it applies to I
can imagine different moral systems
having different answers to that
question right some would be for all
conscious creatures or Ascension
creatures some would be for human beings
some would have a nuanced in between
kind of you where sufficiently
intelligent creatures would count under
your moral system and others wouldn't
some would say that some moral
strictures apply to some creature than
others so I think all these are on the
table as possible things to think about
the other thing to think about is you
know when I think about morality I don't
think that there are sharp bright lines
anywhere I think that morality is kind
of a fuzzy thing and we should be better
at embracing that and accepting it or at
least not living in denial about it that
doesn't mean it's not super important
and you shouldn't work hard to be moral
but you should realize that it's not
like a mathematical proof or something
like that right it's a little bit more
subjective more than little bit more
subjective than that
Igor parshkin says in Quantum field
Theory why is it why is the invariance
of the lagrangian that we require and
not the equations of motion how do we
know our Theory requires this exact
invariance so I don't think it's true
that we require invariants of the
lagrangian rather than the equations of
motion I mean maybe there's a subtlety
because sometimes you have an equation
of motion and a symmetry and and the
thing is that the
symmetry acts to change the equation but
it changes every term in exactly the
same way so the underlying solutions to
the equations are not changed whereas
you might have a situation where the
lagrang gene is simply unchanged so
again for those of you who don't know
the nice thing about a lagrangian a
lagrangian is an expression from which
you can derive many different equations
of motion at once so you might have a
theory that has different kinds of
particles and Fields And whatever in
good old-fashioned Newtonian mechanics
classically you would have to separately
have equations of motion for all of
those pieces of your theory they might
involve interactions with each other but
they would have separate equations the
lagrangian point of view lets you
combine all of the things in your theory
into one expression the lagrangian and
you integrate that overall space time
and you minimize that and those are your
equations of motion
and the great thing about this single
expression is that it not only has
equations of motion for everything but
that it's very easy to implement the
symmetries uh you just look at the
lagrangian as a whole rather than all
the separate equations of motion okay so
there's various conveniences involved in
doing things lagrangian weighing but at
the classical level there's no deep
difference between the lagrang Gene and
the equations of motion you just use one
to get the other Quantum mechanically
there's something extra going on which
is not mentioned in this question which
is that you're not classical anymore
you're quantum mechanical and the
neither the lagrangian nor the equations
of motion are the whole story one nice
way of thinking about that is to think
about the path integral uh you know when
you have a regular integral of a
function f of x you write integral f of
x DX right and f of x is the function
you're integrating DX is the measure it
tells you how much Counts from each
little interval DX the same thing is
true for the path integral formulation
of quantum mechanics you're summing over
all the different possible paths or
histories or field configurations and
what your summing is e to the i s where
s is the action that you get from the
lagrangian but there's also that measure
there in the path integral and you need
to separately have invariance of the
lagrangian end of the measure
if you have a theory and you can very
well have theories I said you remember I
talked in the solo episode about
anomalies that was one of the reasons
why String Theory had a bandwagon that
got launched in the 1980s because people
realized that anomalies could cancel in
string theory and an anomaly is
precisely a situation where there's an
invariance or a symmetry that is there
in the lagrangian but is not there in
the measure that you put in the path
integral so it is a classical symmetry
that is violated by quantum mechanics so
anyway all that is to say it's not the
lagrangian that matters it's the whole
theory that matters some ways of
thinking about the theory might be more
convenient than others
shambles says after listening to all
your podcasts and reading your books it
could be said there's a kind of emergent
Sean Carroll that exists in my brain
perhaps to the point where I can imagine
your response to certain AMA questions
or words or phrases you might use with a
fairly poor degree of accuracy I can
imagine for your spouse or a close
friend their version of you will be much
more real in what ways is the emerging
Sean Carroll in their brains the same
were different to the emergent Sean
Carroll and Sean Carroll's brain
uh I don't so I mean I presumed that by
the immersion Sean Carroll and Sean
Carroll's brain you mean myself I mean
not just me uh having the emergent
person in my brain like I think the
point is that you do model other things
in the universe in your own mind and
that includes the physical Universe it
also includes people right so you have
different ideas about how people will
act what they will do they might be
probabilistic or approximate and so
forth they might be more nuanced once
you get to know people more some people
might not need a lot of information to
model them very effectively they're very
predictable other people will need a lot
of information to think about them and
they're less predictable
so you know I think that
it is I'm not exactly sure what the
question is to be to be honest or how
best to answer it you know I think that
whenever you try to imagine what another
person is going to do you will
inevitably oversimplify right you don't
know all the details about what is going
on in someone's brain to get them from
point A to point B sometimes you don't
have to right sometimes the answer is
just obvious or you know it or you've
heard it before other times the answers
can be very tricky this is what makes
human beings so delightful that they're
not quite so predictable so you know you
don't have enough room in your brain to
accurately model many other people
because their brains are also pretty
complicated but it will you know differ
in the details absolutely from person to
person I'm not sure if that's in any way
a satisfactory answer but it's the best
I can do
P Walder says you have provided an
explanation for how the core Theory can
fully account for the matter we engage
with in our everyday lives including
neurons in brains is this now the
accepted view in the physics Community
or are there gaps in the explanation
which would allow for yet to be
discovered energy fields to play an
explanatory role without having to
create a whole new physics paradigm
I think it is overwhelmingly uh the
accepted view among people who have
thought about it that much which is not
that many people right it's the kind of
thing where when you tell a professional
physicist what this claim is they will
think about and go yeah okay that sounds
right
there are some well-known uh counter
examples there are absolutely
professional physicists who want to
think that the fundamental laws of
physics as we currently understand them
will need to be updated even to take
account for things that we see in the
everyday world so they're out there but
I think they are a dramatic minority I
think that the more important thing is
that most people haven't even asked
themselves the question
Chris V says do you have any guidance
for folks who work in intellectual
Fields curiosity learning and Inter
iterating on ideas is wonderfully fun
however I often find myself lost in
thought or living in my head have you
experienced this yourself and if so do
you have any advice for separating that
aspect of your life in order to be more
present in others
so I'm not exactly sure whether you are
focusing in on being a productive
intellectual or being a productive or
maybe productive is in the right word
being a successful person who is also an
intellectual but uh working but
appearing sometimes in non-intellectual
contexts so there's two issues when you
when it comes to sort of being lost in
thought one is that your job is an
intellectual job you know to come up
with ideas and talk about them and test
them and so forth there are absolutely
people who like the part where they get
to think and don't like the part where
they gotta work to explain their ideas
to somebody else or to develop them
fully or to write them down or whatever
if that's the issue then you know
there's one thing which is being
intellectual and thinking there's
another thing which is earning a living
at it
and earning a living at it absolutely
means you got to do the work you gotta
really uh put in the effort to turn your
thinking into something that is
productive for other human beings
there's nothing bad about that you know
by all means spend your time thinking
but if you want that to be your job then
your job involves also talking to other
people if what you're getting at is uh
you love thinking and you get lost
inside your head and then the person
you're having dinner with says hey
you're not paying attention to me that's
a very different kind of issue to worry
about uh I think that's just a matter of
politeness you have to be able to
balance the fact that it is fun
to think about things to get lost in
your head to dream about things with the
fact that there's a time and place for
doing that and you know we all know
Charming people who are kind of
absent-minded uh there's famous stories
about intellectually accomplished people
who were kind of unable to get through
the day tying their shoes and so forth
you know the charm only goes so far I
think that most people if you're smart
enough to be good at intellectual work
you're also smart enough to tone it down
in certain circumstances where it is not
appropriate
Josh Charles says when looking through a
telescope at a Galaxy is it fair to say
that those photons are branching their
wave functions by interacting with my
retina for the first time since being
emitted or would that have happened when
the first lens it encountered
uh well it happens both so you know very
often a photon that is emitted from an
atom in some astrophysical event has a
wave function that moves in more or less
a spherical pattern away from its source
and what will happen is it will bump
into that spherical wave function as a
probability of bumping into various
things along the way so if you have lots
of little atoms around the event and
maybe some of those atoms are in the
form of telescopes somewhere in the form
of eyeballs but some were just in the
forms of rocks and things like that
for each thing that the wave function
could bump into there's a branch where
it does and then in the wave function
disappears in that Branch from all the
other directions in which it was moving
but then there's the other Branch where
it didn't hit that thing you're talking
about and it continues to move on in all
of these different directions and then
it could be absorbed by something else
so that's just to say that the ultimate
set of all the branches of the wave
functions are ones in which that Photon
has been absorbed by many different
things throughout the universe so
there's a first time it gets absorbed
but in the rest of the wave function it
keeps going and it will be absorbed and
branched further down the road depending
on what it hits
says if I was a lowly patent Clerk and
came into possession of earth-shattering
new physics how could I go about
attributing credit to myself and is
there any chance I can pull it off
without getting rumbled
you know I think that this very question
really is completely upside down it it
it it shows
um that you don't not really familiar
with how Academia works
the it is absolutely possible to have
your ideas stolen okay in Academia but
the way that that happens is precisely
that you don't tell anybody about your
idea except for maybe one or two people
and those one or two people go and scoop
you okay that's how it happens once you
put a paper into the public domain
whether it's on archive or in a
publication or even just on your website
then you have priority if there's a date
on it that is verifiable then someone
else can try their best to write a paper
and say hey I thought of this but the
whole rest of the world can just say no
no it appeared here earlier right there
there's no issue when you put a paper
out into public that's when you get to
claim it that's it that's when you get
the idea the idea that by putting a
paper a result into public it will get
stolen is precisely backwards It Is by
not putting the idea out there into
public that it can get stolen okay
especially if it's a true idea if you
actually come up with something correct
you're not going to be the only person
who comes up with that idea someone else
is going to hit on it before too long so
all of the incentive is to get it out
there into public as soon as possible
so in terms of if you're not a
credentialed scientist where do you put
it Etc the best thing is to put it on
the archive but you need to get
um some endorsement from some person who
knows you who has talked to you who
already has the ability to put it on the
archive and then can endorse you to also
put it on there if you find yourself
never having talked to a professional
scientist about your work then I think
that the chances that your work is
really Earth shattering are probably
very small certainly that is not the
condition that Albert Einstein when he
was a patent clerk was in in any sense
of the imagination
Rue Phillips says I am writing a book on
prediction I spent a couple of years and
got a solid foundation but eventually
got stuck I write in a robotic voice not
super interesting and I'm not especially
skilled with grammar language Etc enter
chat GPT I'm doing an experiment where I
revise my chapters using gpt4 with a
particular tone it is making great
improvements along with better structure
and even providing additional examples
to include it has unblocked me however
I'm now worried that I'm a fraud or the
no lit agent or publisher would want to
touch it what are your feelings about
the situation I'm in or what advice can
you offer
I think this is a great question this is
a question that is going to become very
very important down the road
um and I don't know really what the
right thing to do here is my I'll give
you an impression which is sort of you
should think of it as my first
impression subject to being updated
later as I think about it more and we
learn how this goes which is that
chat GPT or gpt4 or whatever these are
tools that you're very very welcome to
use if they help you write then that's
great but maybe you want to give credit
to them like maybe you want to say the
acknowledgments of your book I used this
tool to help me write or whatever I
don't think that there's anything tawdry
about using this tool any more than
using a dictionary or a calculator or
whatever having said that there's one
huge footnote here which is very very
important which is that unlike a
dictionary where some people sit down
and consciously compile it and then
offer it out there into the world for
you to buy
these large language models have been
trained on other people's writings
so it's completely legit to worry that
things that are written by chat GPT Etc
are just plagiarized in some sense
they're not literally plagiarized
because chat GPT remixes them to be
completely unrecognizable in some way
but they were trained on something and
those some things were written by other
people
so I would tread very very carefully you
know I would I would use it you know I
have a friend who uses the iching to
make difficult decisions you know you
cast some stones or some sticks and then
you look up in a book what it's advising
you
he doesn't actually think that they
Chang is predicting the future or
anything like that the point of using
the tool is to shake yourself out of
your rut right to roll some random
numbers get a suggestion and then think
about the suggestion go like do I like
that suggestion do I not like it or
whatever I think that's the best way
right now to use these AI tools not to
do your work but to inspire you to do
better work if you can come up with a
better way of writing a better metaphor
or whatever that is inspired by playing
around with chat GPT I think that's okay
that's no different than being inspired
when you're writing a novel by reading
other people's novels right you're not
rewriting the same novel but you can
absolutely get stylistic points or
inspiration or things like that I think
that's how you should treat AI models
but again all this is very new and
changing rapidly and subject to update
without notice
Anonymous says there is renewed interest
in psychedelics for mainstream media and
institutions like Johns Hopkins have you
any thoughts on this you want to share
either the renewed interest or the
compounds effects themselves yeah I'm
very much all in favor of it uh we did a
podcast back a while ago with Robin
Carhart Harris who's one of the world's
leaders in this field I think that
research into psychedelics got a bad rap
back in the 60s for cultural reasons not
for scientific reasons and you know you
can use them for pleasure but you can
also absolutely use them for therapeutic
reasons and I'm not an expert but my
vague impression about how to think of
it is that there's various syndromes in
the human mind that come about because
you get stuck you get stuck in a vicious
cycle or a rut or whatever it can be
PTSD or depression or addiction you know
there's various ways in which the brain
kind of gets stuck in a bad place case
and this kind of thing is exactly what
psychedelics are pretty good apparently
in the in terms of the tentative
research that's been done at breaking us
out of so I think that there's
potentially enormous possibility for
using psychedelics for good therapeutic
reasons we need to understand what the
side effects are Etc and I like I said
and not an expert so I don't but I'm
pretty optimistic that this is something
that's going to be very useful going
forward
emerge holographic says atheists often
take the stance that reincarnation is
impossible that we get one life and
that's it
but it would seem to me that placing
such importance on one life is actually
granting exceptions to consciousness
we used to be dead before we came to
life so why can't that happen again what
is the functional difference between
pre-life death and post-life death that
makes them mutually exclusive
I think that there is an actual simple
answer to this which is that
it is true that I can take the raw
materials of a person you know the atoms
the hydrogen and carbon and oxygen and
what have you that has died and their
body you know ceases to be in existence
Etc
um but I can take all of their atoms and
I can imagine reassembling them into a
different person the important thing is
that there's zero sense in which that
person is the same person that you
started with because they don't have any
continuity of memory or of experience or
anything like that so there's nothing
special about the state of your atoms
pre-death versus post-death but there is
a cessation of your Consciousness that
is irretrievable once you're dead in
that sense you're not coming back
Sid Huff says the idea of the Multiverse
seems to be having its day in the Sun
the June 24th issue of The Economist
included an editorial discussing how
popular the Multiverse concept has
become in modern Cinema the article
suggests that the popularity of the
Multiverse might be responding to some
deeper yearning perhaps that reality
might be more complicated than
previously thought theoretical physics
aside do you sense that the growing
awareness of the Multiverse idea is
emerging from a deeper yearning in
humanity a short answer no I think that
that there's nothing new about this deep
yearning right I think that you know
there are ideas that sort of catch fire
in popular imagination
and if someone uses the idea of a
Multiverse in a movie or in a novel or
whatever it's probably because they saw
it in somebody else's movie or novel or
something like that I don't think it's
because Humanity has developed a new
deep learning yearning and also I don't
quite agree with the diagnosis that the
there's a yearning that reality may be
more complicated than previously thought
I mean maybe that's true but I think
there's a much more straightforward
reason why the Multiverse is so
fascinating from a narrative point of
view it's that you and I have in our
heads different alternative histories
right have you ever done something in
the past that you regret have you ever
thought of how things would be different
had you done them differently or had
things happened differently I think that
for 99.999 ETC percent of humanity the
answer is yes and the Multiverse in the
narrative sense allows you to explore
those possibilities how your life could
have been different that people care
about their own lives basically right
that's really when it comes down to it
what they're interested in so of course
there's alternative histories and you
can tell stories of alternate histories
without imagining that they're literally
there in the Multiverse but imagining
that they are there in the Multiverse
puts a little bit more oomph to them
right imagining that there's a version
out you out there who did ask that
person to senior prom or whatever I'm
not sure if it's a if it's valid to
think that way and just think of these
things as completely hypothetical rather
than caring about whether or not they're
actually out there in physical reality
would be my personal advice
Michael Lacey says Tim Maudlin mentioned
that quantum entanglement might enable
faster than light communication under
certain conditions what are your
thoughts on the likelihood of this being
possible it seems that it would wreak
havoc with relativity and lead to
paradoxes such as information traveling
backward in time and arriving before it
was sent
well I think it's super duper unlikely
honestly uh you know Tim was very vague
about what exactly the claim was and it
seemed to be in the context of Bohemian
mechanics in particular which I don't
think is the right version of quantum
mechanics so one of those things where
uh very unlikely to come true if it does
come true it'll be big I wouldn't rule
it out a priori right I mean physics got
along pretty well for hundreds of years
without realizing that the speed of
light was a limit on anything so we
could go back to that just because you
can go faster in the speed of light
doesn't necessarily mean you can go back
in time to be super duper careful about
it if relativity is true
and you can go faster than the speed of
light then you can go back in time but
under these theories maybe relativity
just isn't true maybe there's some other
way of slicing space time so that you
can't go backwards in it so I don't know
exactly what the idea is uh I would be
open to the possibility of it but my
Credence on it ahead of time would be
very very small indeed
love feels best says if I crafted a
glass sphere with a perfectly reflective
interior mirror surface
and I inserted light into it along with
a tiny camera would we see light forever
from a device receiving the camera's
signal uh nope you would not and the
reason is because when the camera
detects the light that Photon or
whatever it was stops existing so you
can't say both that you have a glass
sphere with a perfectly reflective
interior mirror and that there's a
camera in there you can say one or the
other if you did just have a perfectly
reflective interior and we forget about
details like the whole glass sphere
collapsing into a black hole or whatever
then the light would stay inside
bouncing around forever but once you
start observing it you start attenuating
it and it would go away
Sam Hartzog says outside of the obvious
difference in rate how does Cosmic
inflation the early Universe differ from
the expansion we observe today if I dot
if I had a dial that let me manipulate
the value of the cosmological constant
and I cranked it up from 10 to the minus
52 to 11. do any phenomological
distinctions remain given the naive
similarities between the two I was
surprised that my perfunctory Googling
didn't turn up any relevant results
well I'm not quite sure what kind of
differences you want you know in terms
of the difficulty in solving Einstein's
equation it doesn't matter what the size
of the cosmological constant is you just
plug in you get the solution
Etc but the cosmological constant is not
a dimensionless number it's a dimension
full number it has a scale so one way of
thinking about that is if you are in
decider space so again you have not if
you have idealize your space time by
saying you have nothing in the universe
other than the cosmological constant
then you would have a horizon and that
Horizon would have a size okay so you
have a physical length scale associated
with the value of the cosmological
constant if the cosmological constant is
large that length scale is small they
are inversely proportional to each other
so you can compare that length scale to
other things to the sizes of atoms or
stars or whatever if your length scale
your Hubble radius or your decider
radius is small compared to the size of
a star then you're not going to have any
stars in your universe and so forth so
there will absolutely be quantitative
differences but it will still at the end
of the day be the same kind of solution
to Einstein's equation underlying the
whole thing
Joy kolbeck says do gravitational waves
from separate black hole neutron star
mergers constructively and destructively
interfere
yeah they do but not that much
usually you know when you think about
observable interference patterns like in
a double slit experiment it's kind of
important that the slits are nearby each
other once you move the two sources far
away from each other then it just
becomes harder to see any interference
patterns so short answer is yes longer
answer is yes but it has no really
noticeable effects on anything that we
see in these events
Colleen Edwards says in your academic
Journey was there one or maybe a few
particular Concepts or ideas in quantum
mechanics that really challenged you
when you were trying to wrap your head
around it
I don't know about that one I think
that's a good question because it's very
hard for me to remember what was going
through my mind when I was in
undergraduate learning Quantum Mechanics
for the first time honestly when you
typically and certainly for me when you
first learn quantum mechanics it's
mostly about doing the problem sets
right which mostly involves solving the
Schrodinger equation
for some potential matching at some
boundary calculating some rate doing the
wkb approximation thinking about
harmonics of and kletch Gordon
coefficients and atomic orbitals you
know all that detailed technical stuff
it's really not about deep conceptual
things these days you know I'm I'm
learning more about quantum mechanics in
a different context when you have
Quantum information and measurement
Theory there's a whole new world out
there of uh different kinds of
measurements you can do and different
results you can get from them and
information being shared between
different Quantum subsystems and all
that is fun but hard so it's hard just
because it's hard I mean it's not like
conceptually difficult I can't get it my
brain is not big enough it's just work
you know it's it's work and it's
rewarding to do the work and get the
answer so you know I taught a course at
Caltech several years ago where I taught
some of that stuff it was very rewarding
to do it and I'm going to try to figure
out that I can sum sorry that I can fit
some of that stuff into a quantum
mechanical textbook
um but not other stuff I don't know I
after you know whenever you're writing a
textbook you have to
take into consideration that you can't
do everything right you have to kill
some of your Darlings and that's going
to be something I need to keep my mind
on and then decide very carefully what
deserves to be in and what doesn't
Anonymous says I really like the
conversation with Brian Lowry on the
socially constructed nature of the self
here's a question related to that it's
possible to socially construct an
identity that's detached from any
physical or tangible living thing for
example a fictional character a
personified concept like Lady Liberty a
sports mascot intuitively I'd think that
as a human being my identity has a
certain Secret Sauce that Spider-Man
will never have no matter how many
movies or Comics or faint Works people
make about Spider-Man is this Secret
Sauce an innate self that I have after
all or is my intuition wrong am I just
another Spider-Man
I think it's a great question and I
think that my favorite answer is that
neither one of those is quite right I
think that Brian is right
to say there is no secret sauce there
there is no separate immaterial uh
Immortal Soul or even mortal Soul or
even immaterial anything uh you are a
bundle a jumble of different impulses
and thoughts and social relations in
various ways and so that gives you some
Freedom that gives you some agency to
shape your notion of self especially in
response to the social world around you
but I don't think it's arbitrary or
unaffected by physical reality I think
that there are also constraints like I
cannot identify as a 10 foot tall person
no matter how much I want to I can claim
that I am but no one's going to take me
seriously but I could identify as all
sorts of different things that do
plausibly comport with the physical
reality around me so I think there's a
give and take an interplay I think that
Brian's point about the social
construction of the self is a good one
but it's not the only thing to say I do
think that physical reality also has a
say and you need to be compatible at the
end of the day I don't have any great
ideas about working that out in full I'm
going to leave that to the psychologists
Jeffrey Siegel says I enjoyed your
conversation with Katie Elliott
regarding the conversation about
traveling back in time before the coin
is flipped if the everettian view is
correct couldn't you have seen the coin
come up heads but then travel back in
time and then end up on a branch of the
wave function where the coin is Tails
instead of heads
well the only honest question the only
honest answer to a question like this is
who knows nobody has a good theory of
time travel in everettian quantum
mechanics as we discussed I think a
little bit in that episode I certainly
have mentioned elsewhere uh there are
theories of how to construct consistent
Quantum states in the presence of closed
time-like curves David Deutsch for
example has put such a theory together
but it's not the whole everettian
apparatus of branching in multiple
worlds or anything like that it's just
the wave function as a whole that he's
talking about so nobody has a sensible
physical picture in which you both have
branches of the wave function worth
different outcomes and time travel that
starts you in one branch and goes back
to a different one so you would have to
make such a setup in order to answer
these questions I thought about doing it
I thought about putting effort into
trying to make that make sense and then
I realized that you know I have a job I
have real work to do and inventing time
travel scenarios is probably not the
most productive thing I can do with my
time but I don't think that you can
claim right now that there is a once and
for all sensible answer to that until
you have some specific scenario in mind
Tara lumagi says considering the new
nanograb results do you think we may be
able to detect a frequency that actually
tells us what space time is made of any
experiments that can help us rule out
quantum gravity versus String Theory
maybe even detect an echo of the Big
Bang
you know mostly no is what I want to say
here I mean by the way it's not quantum
gravity versus String Theory string
theory is an example of a quantum
gravity Theory one that also involves
other things as well but quantum gravity
is part of it but that's just not what
nanograv is doing you know nanograph is
like all other currently available
windows on gravitational waves very very
deep into the classical regime you know
it's gravity sure it's telling us
something about gravity and so far what
it's telling us about gravity is that
general relativity is doing fine but
it's not telling us about quantum
gravity the whole reason why quantum
gravity is hard is because the scales at
which you can detect gravitational
effects are just different than the
scales of which you can detect Quantum
effects and that doesn't change with
nanograv or anything like that you're
not looking at gravitational waves made
by single atoms Etc
but there is you know the one uh there's
a couple of you know caveats there that
might be relevant you know maybe we do
continued data collection and
experiments and we find that we no
longer fit the data with classical
general relativity then you open up a
can of worms but a very delightful can
of worms where you can start saying well
maybe it's quantum gravity or maybe some
other classical Theory or who knows
what's going on this hasn't happened yet
so we don't know what the answer would
be
and you can imagine detecting something
that you might call the echo of the Big
Bang but it's only a poetic kind of
phrase that is to say you can imagine
primordial gravitational waves
we've already talked about them
generated by inflation my impression is
that the predicted amplitude of
primordial gravitational waves generated
by inflation is nowhere close enough to
be detected by nanograph but maybe I'm
wrong about that or maybe everyone's
wrong and maybe there is some particular
feature that you could someday detect or
a phase transition in the early universe
or something like that I just don't know
if we did it would be indirect evidence
it would not be immediately very useful
but it would be a clue to something and
that would be very very exciting indeed
Jonathan bird says besides calculus what
branches of mathematics do you use the
most in your work what would you
recommend for a physics undergrad now
that might not be obvious is there some
little subfield that has been
surprisingly helpful for you you know I
think it depends a lot on what kind of
physics you do
um you know I I think that maybe I'm
being curmudgeonly about this but I have
the following thought in mind there's a
lot of physics students who catch on
pretty quickly that math is kind of
important in this game right in doing
physics and so they get the idea that
they can sort of Advance their physics
knowledge by learning more math by
taking math classes Etc and you know
what they're right it's true learning
more math I mean whether it's analysis
or group Theory or abstract algebra or
topology or whatever can be very useful
to your future physics career however
all else being equal it is less useful
than learning more physics
before worrying too much about learning
more math don't forget to learn physics
learn e m and statmac and classical
mechanics and quantum mechanics and
Quantum field Theory and general
relativity and condensed matter physics
and all those things there's a lot going
on in the world of physics and much of
it doesn't require super advanced math
that requires calculus maybe some
complex analysis if you're in the
quantum mechanics uh side of the world
there's a lot of linear algebra okay
that's maybe the one thing that they
don't teach you enough of because
everyone learns calculus and
differential equations and things like
that some subfields you're going to have
to spend a lot of your time doing
integrals or doing series expansions or
what have you various approximation
schemes wkb and so forth others you're
going to be getting exact results or
you're going to be doing linear algebra
diagonalizing matrices it depends on
what kind of physics you want to do but
almost always the kind of physics that
you are learning will teach to the math
along the way or at least we'll indicate
to you what kind of math it is you need
to know every good general relativity
book teaches you enough about
differential geometry and tensors to get
by there's always more to learn you can
learn the math for its own sake and
that's fun and maybe you end up being in
that small minority of physicists for
whom this extra bit of mathematical
knowledge is super helpful but typically
honestly as a physicist you pick it up
as you need it as you go along you don't
spend your time guessing that maybe this
is going to be useful to you down the
road
Tyler Whitmer says do you think there is
any specific area of inquiry in physics
or philosophy that are being held back
by institutional barriers to
interdisciplinary work that could be
advancing dramatically if more
institutions took the SFI approach
well I don't know about specific areas
but I think that the whole boundary of
physics and philosophy falls into that
category likewise the boundaries of
psychology and philosophy or computer
science and philosophy or biology in
philosophy Etc or for that matter
history and economics or economics and
literature I think that there are
various aspects of Academia that for
reasons that make sense but are
imperfect concentrate on specific
disciplines to the
fail not not failure but to the
detriment of interdisciplinary work
people want to know not just that the
work is good but which area it's in
which department in particular it should
be in and so you have to Target if you
want to do interdisciplinary work you
have to you know come up with some
justification for this particular kind
of interdisciplinary work you know the
interdisciplinary work of physics and
philosophy and the foundations of
physics and so forth that's a kind of
work that is very important we're trying
to build up that effort here at Johns
Hopkins
um SFI is doing a different kind of
thing right it's looking at complex
systems which is a different area which
I also think is interesting but it's not
exactly the same kind of thing so I
think that you have to
have a particular area in mind area
every area is going to be different and
then you have to figure out how to make
it work right where it could work who
what kind of people remember when I was
talking about core mcarthy and SFI I
said the individual people matter a lot
you know the barrier to physics and
philosophy getting along uh better is
partly that there are institutional
barriers to it but also partly that the
individual physicists and philosophers
aren't interested right some of them are
many of them have been on this podcast
but most of them are not and that's sad
in some sense it makes me a little bit
sad they don't see the beauty of it and
the Intrigue of it that I do but um you
know that's more work for me more things
for me to do so I'm I'm I don't have an
overall theory of how to do this I think
you have to do it on a case-by-case
basis we're trying to do it in
foundations of physics
um philosophy of quantum mechanics
space-time Arrow of time statistical
mechanics cosmology all of those things
there's plenty of room for great work to
be done at those interfaces
okay the last question of this overly
long AMA is from Nikita lasovani nope
there's no end there lozo boy
do you sometimes think about the future
of humanity specifically whether we are
going to reach other habitable worlds
and if yes how or if we are going to be
confined within earth and solar system
quarters until humanity is extinguished
due to the environment becoming
uninhabitable or due to lack of Natural
Resources Etc
yeah I mean I think about it you know I
don't want Humanity to become
extinguished I think eventually it will
happen right you you know I don't know
if it matters to our current planning
strategies but we're not going to be
immortal we are going to equilibrate
we're headed toward thermal equilibrium
but that's a long way off so we have
plenty of time I suspect that Humanity
Will Survive and it will expand beyond
Earth it will expand to the solar system
and beyond some people worry that you
know the stars are too far away and that
it's a science fictiony scenario to
imagine traveling to them but in reality
if you're hard-nosed about it it would
take too long I think that's wrong
because I think it's easy it's not
possible to go faster than the speed of
light but it is easy to live a very long
time it's much easier to solve the
problem of longevity than it is the
problem of FTL travel so the the Galaxy
is some tens of thousands of light years
across you know give us a few million
years there's no reason at all that we
shouldn't be able to fill the Galaxy uh
it's the word We There is doing a lot of
work millions of years is a very long
time on human evolutionary time scales
especially now that we're entering a
technological era where we have not only
computers and AI but Gene editing and
synthetic biology and things like that
so whatever it is that ends up traveling
to other parts of the Galaxy might end
up looking very different than we humans
looked now but I'm overall optimistic
that we will not kill ourselves and I
suspect strongly that if we don't kill
ourselves we will not just stay here on
Earth we are going to travel to the
Stars
that's an optimistic place to end thanks
as always for supporting mindscape on
patreon and elsewhere uh hope you have a
good month talk to you next week bye
[Music]